you have one week left to get your
aparri slash trash taste merch
only one week left to grab it grab it
now it has beautiful embroideries on it
like the after dark design and the
regular trash taste design as well as
t-shirts and sweatpants show it off gone
look at this look at this look at this
you know what this is the first time
light mode is gonna look this good yeah
it's embroidery we wanted it to last
this time the merch is a little bit more
pricey than before but it will last and
it will be around for a long time and
the quality is insane we've promoted the
party many times and every time their
merch sells out so we know you love
their quality and of course for every
person who does buy any of the trash
taste items you'll get a special
personalized postcard from the boys just
for you so you have one week left to get
your merge and i gotta be honest if you
ever approach us wearing this trash
taste much you'll get a firm crisp hug
and a handshake from me a chef's kiss as
well maybe a kiss on the lips who knows
i don't know it's the final countdown
so if you'd like to grab your hands on
the trash taste merch because after next
week it's going to be gone forever go
down links in the description below grab
some for yourself back to the episode i
need to hydrate
oh dear my throat is awfully parched
is it quenched now
[Music]
do you know where i learned the words
parched and quenched where nintendogs
when it says that you need to give your
dog water it says parched and then when
you give the dog water it says quenched
i think i learned the word parched in
from the film inside man or inside job i
can't remember which one it is i think
it's inside man because there's an
interrogation there's an interrogation
scene yeah and the guy's like
can you give me some water please my
throat is parched and then the guy is
just like bro no one says their throat
is part shut the [ __ ] up shut the [ __ ]
up and tell me what's going on hello and
welcome to another episode of trash
tastes such a weird way to remember a
word i don't know vivid of a memory
isn't it so where'd you guys learn new
words from because like i told you
nintendo sometimes you just hear a word
and that like that sticks with you vg
games i learned
games movies nowadays i pronounce
something incorrectly on on a [ __ ]
video or live stream i got ten thousand
comments and emails telling me i
pronounced it wrong yeah that's a pretty
good way i thought english was your
first language
uh yes hello this is trash taste it is i
uh the biggest miku fan apparently uh
idol simp guns right here you look like
you're about to go on an idol closet
yeah so we're recording two episodes
today so we have to like change clothes
i guess i just gave that away um and
there was nothing else in the office
aside from miku stuff so today i am the
biggest miku fan and uh with me is of
course the second biggest miku fan right
now don't call me out this was subtle
merch bro
i didn't even know that was miku yeah
it's me
no i should know
[Laughter]
if i if i if i turned around people
would be able to see very clearly
yeah they don't even see that it's
business in the front yeah fun in the
back
and then there's just joey you know the
usual whatever
the actual miku oh yeah and uh merry
christmas everyone
i guess this is uh coming out on
christmas it's also the last episode of
the year yeah
because the next episode is going to be
coming out first of january we didn't
even plan that [ __ ] out
um no i guess that's just how the stars
aligned when did the last episode come
out of like did it come out on new
year's eve or did it come out on new
year's day i think it came out yeah like
new year's eve i think because i
remember just getting drunk with chris
and that was like the first
the first episode of the year right yeah
yeah yeah so i think it must have been
after new year's day then that doesn't
feel like a year ago it doesn't feel
like 10 years ago
my god like where did this year go
because it feels like the past two years
have just like flown by i mean 2020 just
disappeared in a flash obviously because
everyone was just inside and depressed
but like this year i feel we were able
to go out a little bit more at least in
japan we're able to go out a little bit
more than last year but i think in our
case we just had so much [ __ ] going on
that it all just like seems like a blur
i mean i was i thought i was busy in
2020 and then 2021 was like allow me to
introduce myself and then yeah every
like you know on the uh on the iphone
calendar yeah yeah like when you have
something on the iphone calendar like
you have something on that day there's
like a little dot to symbolize it so
yeah it's very easy on iphone to see how
busy your past couple months were
because every month i came up to the
next month and i was like yeah i'll be
i'll be a lot more free next month like
this is super busy next month though no
dots enter that month
all dots
like oh cool i had three days off last
month no wonder i'm [ __ ] tired yeah
it's it was really
surreal seeing just your calendar fill
up because i remember when i first moved
to japan i i thought who needs a
calendar we're youtubers we don't need
calendars we make our own schedule you
move to japan and slowly you're just
like maybe i need a calendar just to
like keep track of like one or two days
and then more stuff keeps creeping in
and you're just like oh wait i need to
put my personal life on my calendar as
well because like now i don't know when
like my mates want to hang out if i have
something going on that day yeah yeah
you know it's like
it's so surreal just being this busy and
i never expected to be this busy in my
life i mean it's definitely a good thing
right like you know it's a very uh
it's a definitely a very privileged
position i would say to be busy and
doing all sorts of cool stuff but like
at the same time you know it's only so
much my body can handle you know that
scene in like every like business movie
where the ceos like put it in my
calendar i i thought that was just a
cliche
oh do i have time for this meeting put
it in my calendar it's only a matter of
time until we all have our own deborah's
pencil [ __ ] in for us i think so i i i i
ironically want an assistant yeah right
i know that sounds terrible i thought
like what the [ __ ] i would never want
one then i'm like oh actually you know a
lot of things could be helped but if i
had someone who helped schedule things
yeah i know a couple of like youtuber
friends who live here that have like
personal assistants and i'm like oh my
god that seems like a [ __ ] lifestyle
i just oh man the thought of having to
like speak to someone
[Music]
and be like hey my life's a mess can you
help me like it's not about that like
i'm i'm i i i feel i don't know how to
explain it i'm embarrassed about having
to get my life in order you know what i
mean that's what it is so it's like
going to the doctor i like i want you to
tell me that i'm i'm [ __ ] at health like
i know that but if i go to the doctor
you i'm gonna have 100 confirmation that
i am unhealthy i just don't want to be
that guy who's like talk to my pa yeah
let me say like if you want to like uh
get permission for stuff or get like i
don't know
you're like okay i i need to be able to
like arrange all this [ __ ] can you help
me do that yeah uh but like i mean some
days like i don't know about three three
four days of the week i pretty much fill
my schedule up from literally like eight
eight o'clock to like midnight yeah it's
like
stuff doing stuff but i like that i like
doing it and live streaming has added a
bunch of time that it needs to be
squished i mean you've put more work on
yourself this year because i feel like
this year is the year that you've really
upped your live stream live streaming
schedule
as like you basically have almost like
three channels now you've got trash
taste you got
your channel
you've got your live stream channel
right yeah because now now i'll do live
streams in the morning or the evening so
if i'm not doing something in the
morning like let's say i have something
at 12 o'clock like you know like we
record trashed or today we did it at 11.
yeah but if we did it at 12 i would be
like all right sick i wake up at eight
i'll live stream until 12. i'll come
here yeah and then i'll like work all
day and then i'll go do something in the
evening and then i'll sleep this is why
i can't watch shows actually this is
what i've realized i literally yeah
i i don't know what joe's excuses i'm
like streaming until i sleep so i
realized i have no time to watch it i
literally have to pencil in the times i
watch anime now right because because
here's here's like the he's like the
ultimatum of every anime youtuber right
yeah because a lot of the times it takes
more work to make a video about an anime
than to watch an anime so i actually
have to pencil in okay this is the time
i'm going to put in into making a video
about anime and here's the time that i
have to pencil in to watch anime and
like the time i pencil to watch anime is
like it's like this the time of
penciling to make videos is like that
yeah this is like the equivalent like
doctors having to like study new
practices to stay on top of that game
yeah i have to watch
i just want to r d i just love to think
that like you know if i was like like
you know if someone was like a maid of
guns it was like hey god you want to
like hang out on x day or next time and
god just being like
sorry man that's anime time
actually
literally there have been times where
sydney's like uh gone can uh we we hang
out on this night and i'm like sorry
sydney it's my anime watching night it's
part of my job i i need to keep up with
like what's get what's airing right now
my friends laugh at me because i have to
like ask them i have to like i send them
email no like invitations to like times
to like hang out yeah yeah let's hang
out i'll send you an email yeah
to like put it in your calendar yeah
because i'll forget and like send them
like a google calendar notification i
think about like the last 10 times i
agreed to hang out with someone at least
on like a call not like in person i i've
never like not turned up in person but
my on-call to hang out with people who
are like i don't get to see often or
people live in other countries yeah i
think like the last
five out of ten that i didn't put in my
calendar i think i like turned up late
or just forgot about yeah if i don't put
it in tonight i feel terrible about that
i'm about a bad friend but yeah if i if
i don't put it in my calendar because
because sometimes sometimes you get like
free time or you think you get free time
you're like
do i actually have free time so you say
whip out the calendar and you're like oh
i do have free time then an hour passes
and get a message and you're like oh
weren't you meant to be what we meant to
have a call or we meant to be hanging
out you're like oh [ __ ] it's a lie it's
so big it's a lie for me it's like for
me the problem is like you know going
back to like the apple calendar thing
i'm like all right that finally i wake
up and i'm like finally a day where the
dot is non-existent i have a day off i
can do whatever the [ __ ] i want but then
i go to my computer i look at my other
schedule that's sitting at my desk and
i'm like oh
i have to edit three videos and do two
sponsors all right so it's not a day off
it's a day to be inside but i'm not
necessarily doing anything outside so
it's not a day off
and uh yeah that's been my life for the
past did you guys have to-do lists
yeah i've been starting to like do to-do
lists now because i have to forget what
i have to do list when i the day i
discovered to-do lists like to do like
like a caveman jumping over a rock yeah
a game changer there's a list of things
i had to do with it
i don't even think cavemen were that
impressed when they discovered fire like
well i i because like one of my friends
honestly dude like especially when it
comes like our stuff because because we
have so many things that we have to do
and so many things that we want to do
yeah right so
my dad actually taught me like how to
make the perfect to-do list which is you
wake up in the morning and you think to
yourself all right you jot down
everything that you can think of that
you can do and that you have to do
you jot it down and then from that list
everything that is super important goes
to the top yeah everything that
everything else that can wait a couple
of days goes to the bottom yeah and then
you go on with your day you tick off
everything that you do and at the end of
the day if you're left with a couple of
things that's all right that becomes the
top of your to-do list the next day
right and just i've been doing that for
the past year and i've become
infinitely productive like i i guarantee
that's what moodon does as well probably
with the imagination
i'm i'm like how do i find more hours in
the day
you seem to like pull from this infinite
pool of hours that i don't know where
you find i don't want to
i just want to know what did mudan
sacrifice you know what
i think you like how did it cost
everything i think he hooked his like
brain and cardo like brain and heart to
a car battery it was just like
constantly just going
i can't wait to come on and explain
himself
it's like just don't sleep
he's awful at like explaining how he's
productive like he doesn't make it sound
realistic he's just like yeah you know i
just wake up in the morning i just do it
yeah he's the epitome of just get good
yeah you like with mood on i only see
like the input and output like input
editing work outputs a video i don't see
like what happens it's basically just
like a black box right it's like the
youtube algorithm because like you kind
of know how it works but no one really
knows the inner workings of the youtube
algorithm that's just like mudan and
editing for me man have you ever seen
mudan edit
is on stream and that's where he's also
doing something else but he's probably
like holding back on streams as well as
people don't get freaked out
sorry
honestly that's how impressive it is
because it's like i i think you know
people already know who watch the show
are aware of just how much he edits for
trash taste and also for me and connor
but i think people forget that you know
other people also ask him to edit oh
he's he's out for sydney now as well
yeah right so i'm just like and not to
mention he edits his own streams and he
streams and he also streams and he also
streams like pretty regularly so i'm
like what how the beast man i would like
to know what i do mudan
episode we're also waiting for the
country to open back up which hopefully
will finally happen next year as well
ish that's the biggest thing i'm hoping
for um i think it'll i mean it's gonna
happen next year it's just when it's
like is it going to happen early or late
that's that's the you know that's the
big question i think everyone is saying
uh like as early as maybe feb or march
right i think much would be nice
visitors can come in because right now i
think uh if you're a non-visitor so if
you're like a student or you're on work
fees or stuff like that you can
technically come in now yeah um not that
i've seen any actual examples of people
coming in well i assume they need to get
real i haven't looked into the process
but i assume they need to reapply for
some kind of problem application
yeah um because you know not tourists
but at least if you have a working visa
or you've been waiting
for like a job or to study here then you
can come here which is which is good
which is like it shouldn't have taken
two years to get to this point
i feel bad for the students man yeah i
know right just being like finally i get
to live my dream of coming to japan no
it makes me feel so bad because like
when we applied we have to wait like
what three months and that was just like
the worst three months right because
it's not it's not the fact that it's
three months it's the fact that it's
three months where you don't know what's
going to happen in your life and you're
just like your your life is kind of in
limbo until you get that confirmation to
be like oh okay finally i can start
packing i can start preparing to go and
then but while you're waiting you're
just like uh should i start should i go
what's kind of going on in my life right
now i was wondering with the students
thing i was thinking like okay we had no
way of knowing that it's gonna take two
years for japan to open yeah and and
like
i don't know what i i haven't really
spoken to any students about it but like
what was like if you got to like you're
like day one right you find out japan's
closing like do you just like wait and
see or do you just decide to do
something else and then like hope and
hope that you can just then go back i
don't know i think i think for most
students i don't think anyone was
anticipating
them to [ __ ] stay in limbo for two
years right so i'm sure the majority of
students were like oh you know i you
know i still got time i can wait imagine
losing two years of like i guess
progress you could have made in your 20s
yeah yeah but then again it's not it's
not really that important because i
guess a lot of people in in life didn't
start doing the their main thing until
they were like 40. so i guess it really
doesn't [ __ ] oh yeah yeah sure i mean
but i think what sucks is that you just
have two years where you can't really
commit to something you know that's
that's what really sucks for me where i
i always want to have a goal that i'm
working towards and know that i'm
actively working towards that goal
because one one of my biggest pet peeves
is like if i feel like i'm not working
towards something then i just feel lost
and i i just feel like a [ __ ] lost
soul and i need i need i need something
concrete to work towards yeah that's why
like i really empathize to anyone
waiting for a visa and thank god you
guys can finally come here hopefully you
get here soon get to eat some superman
that's the number one thing [ __ ] the
sushi [ __ ] the ramen go to your local
skimming joint and discover true
happiness yeah we had we had the
michelin star ramen oh yeah we did and
it was very exciting we didn't know it
was michelin star right so there's a it
was the place man recommended to it yeah
yeah was it ramen because i i thought it
was sober no it's ramen it's like chu
casaba which is like chinese soba which
is like technically some people call it
ramen the noodles are more ramen noodle
um
it was
very light for a ramen it was very light
because like when i when you said like
ramen i was just like oh it's going to
be a heavy ramen because ramen's the
kind of meal that like takes you out it
knocks you out for like an hour yeah
when i was thinking about it i'm like
okay what do i i think i have the wrong
expectations of michelin star the guy
expects some kind of stupid luxurious
like gourmet thing but i guess it's more
about value
yeah it was like a thousand yen i like
the one i got was like ten bucks yeah
yeah i mean like eight dollars right i
guess like it's amazing i have a picture
of it it was it was very good but the
whole time i was thinking i was like i
think tsukemen is more tasty i think i
think
was better than the michelin star robin
i agree honestly i i didn't enjoy the
ramen that much and
okay so because here's the thing right i
feel like michelin star if you've been
to enough of them especially in japan
because it's like in japan there's so
many michelin star restaurants but i
i've realized that you cut with michelin
star you come in with like the wrong
expectations right yeah and this is
going to make me sound you know this is
going to make me sound so [ __ ]
privileged no
michelin stars aren't all that great
about michelin star it's the michelin
star but like here here's the thing the
retirement no
like here's the thing when you go into a
michelin star restaurant your
expectations are like up here you're
like
knows all well because he often
frequents the mission of course of
course no but like you you you come in
with these expectations that you you're
gonna get like a meal that's a cut above
the rest yeah right and so you start
judging things harsher than if you just
go to this random restaurant and just
like
find out that there's like amazing food
because in japan i feel like there is
just as many restaurants that have food
that are like michelin star quality that
just haven't been discovered yet you
know and i've and
to me like michelin star isn't always
the indicator of this is the best meal
that you can get in japan what it only
means is that it's it's become famous
enough that people have started to
notice it but there are so many there
are so many hidden gems and like for
example with the michelin star ramen
that is not like the best even the best
ramen that i've had with the best i've
had i've had like
i've had like sketchy ass places
yeah i i i honestly think the uh the
insect ramen i had for my video was
actually better yeah
and that has a hundred times
it's not sitting on the street
we haven't named the ramen place because
i also don't want to like [ __ ] make
it i'm saying that because the insect
ramen was actually [ __ ] amazing no
and and also like because it's michelin
star it actually made it a worse
experience for me right because because
because you wait in line because
expectations are too high right one yet
your expectations is high and two it's
really really [ __ ] busy right so in
this ramen shop it's a tiny ass ramen
shop it's it's like when we say michelin
star it's a really it's a normal ramen
shop right ramen stores in general are
like not i would say they're good dining
experiences yeah like you it's not it's
like if you're if you want to come here
and chill out with your friends don't go
to a ramen it's it's a come in eat and
go yeah yeah yeah i mean it only that
place only said like what 10 or 12
people maybe yeah yeah it's busy it's
like narrow you're like if you're even
remotely large then larger than normal
you're gonna have a tough time
squeezing past everyone and like we went
at about 2 p.m so not even like not even
close to peak time and we still have to
wait like a good 20 minutes like 20
minutes and this is this is when the
country is closed the tourists so when
tourists come back in i was talking to
some people who've waited for this ramen
for like an hour an hour and a half two
hours right and you get you get shepherd
in and then you you're expected to just
eat the ramen and leave right there's no
there's no down time you get given a
bowl you eat it and then leave you going
like to me part of like the food
experience is just
like not feeling pressured to eat the
food but just yeah but just like feeding
like i can take my time to enjoy this
food yeah i couldn't i couldn't even
like bask like as good as the ramen was
i couldn't bask in it because there was
the pressure of oh i could take my time
with this but i'd also be pissing off
the 20 other people still waiting in
line exactly right standing outside this
is why i've realized that ramen is best
at like midnight yeah you can just like
because they they have time they always
serve beers everyone's having like a
good time in there like it's a way more
fun atmosphere like some of the stores
that open 24 hours normally have a few
more seats as well it is the ultimate
midnight snack for sure it's
honestly it's awful for your stomach
there's a good chance you might like
bring it back up but yeah but some of
the best ramen experiences i've had like
midnight we're in like a sketchy area of
some place in japan
everyone's drinking beers in the store
it's cool atmosphere everyone's talking
it's so much more fun than ramen during
the day where everyone's just there to
eat and get out yeah the best the best
ramen experience i had was when i was
absolutely shit-faced yeah at like 2am
and then my friend makoto was like
like 2 am and i was like uh okay so we
ran around the corner to this like awful
sketchy place like the ramen wasn't even
that good but just like fun it's just
fun like when the moment it went down i
was like damn good to feel alive but
then the moment you walk out it's like
oh it's awful all right yeah because
you've ruined your stomach with you i'm
about gonna die
because to me like the restaurant
experience goes beyond just the the
taste of the food right there's there's
like a reason why your mom's cooking
always tastes [ __ ] good right it's
because it's cause like because cause
that cooking means something to you you
you you know you know where's the heart
man what's the heart in the brain
honestly honestly you can taste in some
japanese restaurants where they put the
heart into the cooking oh yeah and like
it's so obvious with some like very
small
i mean i i just think that i just
i realize that i don't like ramen as
much as i want to like ramen like oh no
like i i uber eats men on sometimes all
right and that [ __ ] is [ __ ] good yeah
because because also ramen travels
terribly that's why never ever order
ramen it's i mean unless you have like
one of those really old star ones where
they like bring you the actual bowl with
everything that's that's the only one i
get problem is nowadays with ramen with
ubrites they separate the noodles and
the broth so they give you a broth and
like a plastic really a lot of the time
yeah they don't actually put the noodles
in you put the noodles in yourself yeah
it's not good and the noodle's supposed
to be like piping hot in the in the
broth so it doesn't really work but
it travels pretty oh like i'm pretty
okay because you it's because the broth
is so thick it's like magma yeah the
broth is so thick it stays really hot
and the noodles are supposed to be
separate anyway yeah and then you just
dunk the noodles in and it's almost as
good yeah no i wouldn't say it's
definitely better in shop but yeah yeah
yeah but like if you're you're you know
you're uh you need that you need that
edge
man i've been advocating because like
ramen ramen is that one japanese dish
where before i moved to japan i was just
i was thinking oh i'm gonna eat ramen
every [ __ ] week every day
i've had ramen three times the past week
though really but i didn't have ramen
for like months before that oh yeah yeah
i was saying like the last time i had
ramen before we went to this michelin
star ramen place uh was
like i think a year before a year before
that's just because i have like zero
craving for ramen because why would i
have ramen when i can have tsukimen
right
like but the one dish that i haven't got
bored off though is a sushi like i eat
sushi at least one once a week really at
least once a week damn you eat more than
me
and i love sushi i probably go maybe
like yeah two or three times a month i
wish that was like a really quick and
easy one near my house i would probably
go i just i don't want to order it yeah
no it doesn't order well but like i i
feel like there's there's a few conveyor
belts she's near my place and it's just
perfect for lunch man it's it's like
there's like 100 yen because i even like
the 100 yen sushi which is like 80 80
cents for like one piece of like salmon
or something yeah it's so good yeah
honestly like my experience with sushi
in japan is that you know you they you
know i've i've also you know melin's
taking me to some michelin star sushi
places as well and of course she has
only eats if there's michelin
she's like i don't see the michelin men
anyway i'm not going basically part of
the big reason why we've gone to more
michelin star places is because you know
melin suggested these places to us
where's buy it yeah which is how we
found the mid the the robin place which
is made and recommended the robin place
and it happened to be michelin star but
uh you know i i have tried like a few
like a lot of different sushi places of
like different price points and my
honest opinion is that
like sushi
you reach about like you know you reach
about like thirty dollars a meal for a
sushi which is about you know mid mid
sushi uh in japan right it's not cheap
it's not expensive and that's about as
good as it gets to me because
you go you go you can get sushi from
like like thirty dollars like a hundred
dollars like two hundred dollars gourmet
super famous chefs out there like how
dare you guys yeah
and like my like my honest opinion is
that i've i've had the expensive sushi
and i'm just like
it's better but it's not that much
better than like the 30 sushi that i can
get that's how it always is though like
i find that the meals that are a little
more pricey than the the you know the
normal ones are generally like the the
nice ones and then when you get to the
stupid extravagant levels of prices it's
just like not that yeah it's like a 10
10 10 fold increase for like a five to
ten percent better meal you know i i
think i would argue that like if you're
ever going to go to like especially like
the high high-end sushi places which is
all around tokyo then like get something
that you could only get in that high-end
restaurant yeah so like because i
remember i took uh my friend luke to
like the the really high-end sushi place
because he's never been to like a
high-end sushi place so i took him to
the one in um harajuku yeah and it was
like 400 bucks between the two of us
so it's like really rushing a bit
but that place has like uh
uh i i think i don't know if you guys
have been to it but like it's the one
where you can have like the nine
different types of uh sea urchin
different types of seeds yeah yeah so
they do this like especially
yeah so there's a special thing where
they do like nine different types of
seeds we're talking about sushi and you
get
and you get like my stomach
and you get like taste tests like the
different types of sea urchin from like
different parts of japan and around the
world and stuff and like that is like
cool because i'm literally salivating
yeah i'll give you 0
like that is cool because i've only ever
seen that in that store like yeah it's
expensive but that is an experience that
you can only get in that story you can't
go to like a [ __ ] sushi chain right
but like if you're just gonna go to a
high-end sushi place and just order
[ __ ] salmon on the ice then like
there's no point there's no difference
like you're not the average person is
not that much of a sushi snob where
they're gonna be like oh this is this
isn't the high grade salmon that they're
using
it's just like even if it's high grade
salmon it's like a like five percent
increase in how better the taste is and
sushi is basically just it's rice it's
the fish it's the wasabi and it's just
like the soy sauce they put on top and
like it's basically you just have to
like make sure the ratios are right and
then there's only
yeah and then there's only like so much
the fish can be fresh right yeah at
which point do we at which point do we
just like say hey you just can't make
this taste any better with the
ingredients you're given right because
unless you have like like ten times the
number of taste buds than the average
human like it's not gonna change yeah
exactly exactly like my my tongue
doesn't
like i'm not i'm not part of like
shokugeki or something i can't like
taste like the exact percentage of
salinity in the [ __ ] although i must
say when i did try the nine different
types of like uh sea urchin i was ready
to take my shirt off from how good it
was she's like oh i'm just i'm just an
unagi fan man it's my favorite food in
japan unani it's the best yeah but see
like even like unagi right like after a
certain price range it's like oh no no
you can't you can't taste it no no no
yeah but like that's why like
if you just go to an aggie place it's
kind of expensive in aggie in general
but i mean like even like the the lower
lower price point ones i'm always like
satisfied yeah exactly and i think it's
somewhat good for you so that's good is
it it's it's not terrible it's not
terrible it's got a lot of like uh you
know a lot of good uh omegas um those
fishy oils but they are also going
extinct as well that's the reason why
their prices well it's not like japan
eats like 80 percent of the world's eels
or something something like that but
then they there's tons of eels from
other countries it's it's it's 80 it's
like most of japan's eels they have like
nearly yeah yeah they're like almost all
gone that's why they're just getting
more expensive yeah
so i saw like a whole business insider
video on that yeah because they because
japan has a thing of like we don't want
to import foreign things it's low
quality well they're starting like eel
farms now yeah they're where they they
import the eels like as babies from
other countries yeah and grow them in
japan like they're like they're japanese
it's like it's just like japanese eels
yeah
which is why
which is why i realized you know when
you go to a restaurant and they serve
you this like really expensive dish or
really expensive meat right that doesn't
necessarily mean it tastes any better
because a lot of it's like a lot of more
expensive
meats weren't that expensive in history
right so you know the taste hasn't
changed like for example lobsters you
know they they you know they used to be
like peasant food yeah they used to be
like peasant food or you know
[Applause]
these [ __ ] restaurants the ones that
are like the super high end you feel so
[ __ ] out of place because you're not
like an oligarch from russia i don't
feel like i belong there i want to go to
the place that has a cool vibe yeah the
food's a little more uh pricey than
going into like a yacht
or something you know it's like a you
know a little bit more you get a vibe
you have a chill time there's no
expectations you don't have to worry
about how you've been dressed that's the
vibe i like it's a nice time i just want
to have my
12 burger that's like it's better than
mcdonald's but it's it's got a little
gourmet but it's it's not it's not
gourmet but but they put avocado on it
or something i don't know i don't know
just that middle price point is my
comfort zone i'm like this is nice
i just want to feel like the cooks and
the chef care about their foods yeah i i
think that's a big thing for me yeah
when i order a drink and they ask me if
it tastes okay before they serve it to
me that's when i feel like i'm out of my
depth i'm like i i've never done this
before i ordered the thing you give me
the thing yeah is our mission in style
water
for your knees if i order a wine just
give me the wine um even if i told you
even if i told you it doesn't taste good
you should just be you should just laugh
at me and be like yeah well that's
that's you you did like it it's the
small things if i get served food and
like they come to and ask like oh how
was it was it good i'm just like you
know what you know you care enough to
like care about my opinion i meant as in
like they're going to take it back if i
say no yeah no i'm not like am i
enjoying it
but that's the kind of restaurants that
you know when they bring out the dish or
whatever and you look at and you're like
what is this and then a light novel
title of explanation starts right and
it's like i
can i just eat it
it's like two bites i would be done by
the time you finished explaining this
and i wouldn't care otherwise you know
those are the ones where i'm like if i
said if they came up to me and they were
like was it any good and if i
hypothetically said no then they would
be like what can we do to help you
because like what the experience i
remember was during the cycling special
where we uh went to their restaurant
with their grandma who was basically
just like eyeballing us
as we were watching he pretty much
pulled up a chair and sat with us
it was like you aren't feeding you yeah
yeah exactly
i love that place though it's just cause
like when when someone cause because i
get it because like when you cook a meal
for someone and they enjoy that and they
enjoy the food and anything it tastes
good like there's such a there's like
such a rush to that right and i i feel
like i i feel like i've seen enough
chefs who you know obviously obviously
it is a job you know i understand some
some people just do it for a job but
there's just there's just some magic to
a chef or a cook who cooks the food and
just gets such an enjoyment
from seeing people enjoy their food
right because i don't know it's it
doesn't just it's this is this isn't
just chefs but you know if i just see
someone enjoying their job that just
makes my day better you know you know
even if you just go to a [ __ ]
mcdonald's and you see like that one
person with a genuine smile and you're
just like you know what good for you man
you're you're having a good time working
mcdonald's i'm [ __ ] happy i don't
know man if it wasn't mcdonald's i'd be
like oh someone's uh someone's getting
caught because you ordered a smile come
on
which is should i get a smile for that
for some reason on ubereats in japan at
the bottom of the page where you just
order all the stuff there is a muksmile
option
for zero yen and i don't understand how
you would purchase said mcsmile because
i'm not there to see the smile
genuinely go to yeah because in japan
you if you a day is ruined yeah it is a
lie in japan if you go into a mcdonald's
restaurant and you say can i get a smile
please then they'll give it to you so
but yeah but
i was fine with that right i don't i
don't agree with that i don't think
someone should have to smile
but
why the [ __ ] why the [ __ ] on ubereats is
it listed when how is the uber delivery
guy get a smartphone i don't know
because i don't even see him because
they have the [ __ ] drop it off at my
door opposite just [ __ ] like take
take like an instamax
the [ __ ] uber driver just takes a
picture of the mcdonald's employee just
smiling i i don't understand why uber
added this to the menu i'm like what for
what i don't understand how this is
gonna work i added it one time and
nothing happened because it's legally
part of the mcdonald's menu because
obviously nothing is going to happen
when i ordered the mcsmile via ubereats
because what would happen i was just
curious is this is this
a japanese thing
they would never work japanese
the uk they would
employees would quit on the spot they'd
be like i'd rather die than smile
it's like yeah you want a smile please
order it yeah yeah yeah
it's like an actual menu item poor
workers being forced to smile upon
requests
at least give them like a tip or
something you know you can't tip you
can't say you can't tip here so what's
the reason for smiling oh it's because
the customer ordered me to smile smile
enjoy your job
i want someone to encourage me as i
order these 30 nuggets
that will inevitably destroy my body
well what i enjoy is seeing someone
smile without me having to order them to
smile you know just just but in japan
you're like you don't know if they're
doing it because they have to do it yeah
japan is the master of business smiles
at the end yeah i don't know i i feel
like i've been to enough places some
places in japan where i'm just like okay
this is this is like the corporate smile
and we're watching yeah because there's
no way if you turn up like half drunk to
a mcdonald's that they are happy to see
you there like stumbling ordering a
cheeseburger you know what i mean like
there's there's no way anyone is happy
about it do you think you're gonna smile
with that voice
all right i see mates in hockey harbor
and guys i don't think they're really
happy to talk to the customers i don't
know man maybe they're just not excited
to talk to the people that they seem
like they want to do you know you know
when you watch someone smile but their
eyes aren't smiling
that's all that means in our camera
like they sound so chipper and you know
they have a big smile on their face as
they're waving to you like this but deep
in their eyes it's just
all that industry is also dying yeah you
can't be too happy about that i mean
there's like significant amount less of
major um stores or cafes
but now they all have mass on so they're
probably not even smiling
either
how can you how can you tell if they're
smiling now they've perfected the i
sound happy without smiling voice you
know
nico knee
good they shouldn't have to smile yeah
i'm all for people not needing to smile
that's all right i wasn't going to go
into those many cafes anyway so don't
worry about it
really really i've been to one it's
[ __ ] sucked wow yeah i've been to one
as well yeah we've established many
times on this podcast that they are the
worst thing on the world have you been
to one uh no i don't i don't need to go
to one to no i don't want to get it i
i'm violently uncomfortable but it's an
experience you should just try to know
because i know it's so uncomfortable
it's like the most unbritish thing on
earth and i can't i can't do it i can't
like and i've seen like i saw like
offline tv went to one and i'm like i
can just only imagine how awkward this
was when they were in there like this is
terrible i would go back solely for the
reason to take chris with me i would
that that would be an amazing video
that's what i want to do there's a lot
of things i would do just to make chris
suffer
and to make myself suffer as well
can i take you and crystal make up sure
sure we'll see how we'll see how you
guys react to that sure why not
trash taste made cafe special
chris's reactions often are off camera
are almost funnier than his on camera
because
he'll just be like [ __ ] that was [ __ ]
why'd you make me do that see christian
like the love love beam or whatever i
can't remember what they say about it
[Laughter]
i want to see chris do that chris has
gotten to the point where she's the most
entertaining miserable british men like
he's so funny to watch be miserable
because he's perfected the art of like
you don't feel bad for making him angry
yeah yeah you know what i mean yeah like
some people when they get upset or
uncomfortable you're like you feel sorry
for them but chris has perfected the way
of like you'd like he's just you just
just don't feel bad for laughing at
chris but he's he's the only man that
can somehow laugh while having a friend
oh yeah exactly that's right you don't
like but that's what's so good about
being british is that people don't feel
bad for laughing at you when you're
uncomfortable yeah
because people just like they're like oh
he's having a horrible time it's funny
like like to me we've made cafes like to
me it's the perfect determiner to see if
someone's like a lost soul when it comes
to differentiating between like anime
and real life yeah because if you go to
like if you go to like a maid cafe and
you don't feel uncomfortable then to me
that makes it that that makes me feel
like ripped
rooney he's a lost soul right now
because because like
because mates are meant to act like
anime characters right and there's
nothing more uncomfortable to me than
seeing like a real life anime character
like right in front of my art well
because in real life it's like extremely
uncomfortable to see somebody talk that
way it's like yeah please because people
listen
that way just act normal
please just i don't know slap me or
something i don't know anything but this
just talks to me like a human being yes
exactly this episode is sponsored by
shadowverse shadowverse is an awesome
anime card game featuring great art with
a fun loving community of over 1 million
daily battles gentlemen did you also
know that it's free to play on mobile
and pc yeah i know and if you sign up
now they're giving you a super generous
deal that you get 53 card packs just for
completing the tutorial and don't forget
it has an amazing anime art style that
is fully voiced in both english and
japanese it is highly strategic to play
with eight distinct leader classes and a
multitude of cards designed by some of
the world's best card game players and i
hope there's a new expansion and
collaboration that will be coming out at
the end of december 2021 very nice all
right now the script part's over this
game slaps okay
i'm gonna be real look if you know me
you know i actually genuinely love
shadowverse it's an amazing card game
i've reached grandmaster in it twice now
damn um and i can reach it a third time
if i really wanted to just just casual
flex it's a casual flex i can reach it
any time i want it's a great game go
play it all right well that's god's
honest opinion and that genuinely is his
honest opinion look so if you also want
to go play it make sure to use that link
in the description down below to
download shadow of us today back to the
show considering this is our our year
episode what have you guys been up to
this year then what's what's been the
the biggest growth the biggest
disappointments the biggest uh
achievements have you achieved anything
this year
i'm not dead
i'm still alive i guess
we all say that but i think to our
audience it's like well okay okay i can
name off about 50 things okay we have
moved studios uh we've got we've got a
much without having
yeah this is probably the biggest it's
difficult because you don't i often you
don't want to spend too much time
patting yourself on the back because if
you do you often get lost in uh in there
and you you can't be seen you want to
keep pushing forward yeah and never
never be complacent with what you've
done yeah i mean you know i i guess i'm
happy i moved house it didn't really
feel like something that i've achieved
but i felt like it was a big dub yeah
get moving to a better place
you know sorry man sometimes you know
what you have to stroke your own
decisions
that's definitely uh definitely a
minuses the gym has been less apparent
in my life yeah i i need to get started
i'm just happy karen can i say where we
used to live
uh you could i would just say the i
guess
so i'm glad we've moved out of summer so
all that time when we said that we lived
in tokyo that was a [ __ ] lie well we
we lived inside somewhere oh it's not
not exactly it's the greater tokyo
metropolitan okay okay okay it wasn't
like
is zone 6 really london
[Music]
there was like different trains that we
could get to go into tokyo so we could
like either take like the rapid trade
which takes like 20 minutes or something
to get into central tokyo
but like the rapid train is like
only comes with once an hour there's a
unicorn yeah then there's a commuter
rapid oh the commuter
there's the local rapid commuter rapid
the the local stops at every spot
obviously the rapid stops like i'd say
japan are definitely going to feed that
yeah
maybe
i really think so yeah because the
commuter rapid is like only one train
line
oh really well no
there's a few stops that it goes to that
we could live in yeah but like you can i
think people in japan now figured out oh
it's definitely that line that they will
i guess well good thing we don't live
there right now
anymore so there you go
well they wouldn't know they wouldn't
know the exact start yeah yeah it's fine
it's fine but there's because there's
the there's okay there's two lines
inside though that you can get the kane
toku and the the yeah
sucks it stops at every stop it takes
like 10 hours to get anywhere
there's like two lines one of them
actually gets you places the other one
it literally takes like two hours to go
from like the the it's because
goes through four prefectures yeah it's
great yeah it's nuts yeah and then like
where we where like where we used to
live like if you we could plan going
into tokyo right because you can plan to
go this time to get the commuter rapid
it's a fast train but my god going back
was such a pain right shinjuku at like
11 was like nightmare yeah yeah because
you're you'll never get the commuter
rapid you'll never get like the rapid
it's always the local and then you
suddenly a 20-minute commute
turns into an hour you know yeah on the
local train it was uh
like the first few times i was like okay
okay i can do this and then afterwards
especially when we started coming to the
office where we moved office um it was i
wanted to move a lot closer the first
show didn't bother me much i don't
really care much then it got to but yeah
i'm glad we moved uh i mean you know i
liked where we lived actually it was a
nice area yeah it was a really nice area
uh it's just too fast
yeah and i i won't lie the ubereats
selection was shocking you pretty much
you had you had one option for every
cuisine yeah so it was like if if the if
the thai place was bad which luckily it
wasn't though
it was bad okay the typewriters are like
the best place yeah but like
the
all right because
right
like good italian food that delivered
which was like this i feel like this is
the most privileged [ __ ] thing i
don't care i love italian food and i
love getting i don't know if you've
heard of dominoes
that's pretty italian if you want to do
uh pizza they do pizza and pasta there
was one place but it was ridiculously
expensive for me the the biggest thing
that i was missing in the uber's
selection was healthy options oh yeah
there's like no like salad or anything
yeah like if you wanted healthy foods
you needed to cook it yourself and a lot
of the times
a lot of the times i wanted to eat
healthy and then like but i would get
back from work and then the day would be
over
the first world problems god forbid i
chop up lettuce in my own home we like
the ubereats selection was rather poor
this is like pre-oligar like levels of
water i i used to just go out a lot to
eat just because when i did move into
the my previous place i saw the ubereats
options it was like
are you [ __ ] that i'm just gonna go out
yeah
but also you were a lot closer to the
places than i was saying yeah i guess so
i was like nothing new it was nice
though like that area was super nice to
walk around in yeah because
yeah
because like i i feel like i only
started to really walk around and
explore when i was deciding whether i
should move or not
and i was just like oh there's a there's
a lot of cool places a lot of cool cafes
and restaurants that i just didn't
notice before because i'd never bothered
exploring the area and they didn't show
up in ubereat so why how could i
discover them yeah exactly right and uh
yeah like i i feel like there's a lot of
small local places that i miss now but
you know i'm also happy to be in a more
convenient area and i've been be outside
that time i'm just happy we've all moved
into much much bigger and nicer places
now yeah you know and like you know as
good as our previous places were like i
think you know
especially after we got this office i
think it was definitely time for an
upgrade in our in our personal lives as
well
yeah i mean like i
i i i've said this before but i was
happy with my place and i was very lucky
to find the place that i have moved into
um but you know i was i was i was still
pretty happy with my place so
i i
it's it's to to me it's definitely an
upgrade but it's like it's it's like a
natural progression to me and i feel
like there are some things that i've
definitely progressed in in like 2021
and then there's some things that i feel
like i've probably requested regressed
in or stayed the same i don't know it's
been a it's been a weird year because
after 2020 everyone was just like all
right ready to like hit the ground
running in 2021 and then the environment
just didn't allow
us to like hit the ground running yeah
yeah so like i remember like i think for
a lot of 2021 like like you know i can
say this now because i think before
going back to england i was definitely
burnt out like um
i'm saying it's not like i was
definitely burnt out and everyone's just
everyone's just like oh why didn't you
take a holiday why why didn't you take
some time off to uh just look after your
mental health and all that stuff and
what i would say was there was nothing i
could do
there was nothing that i wanted to do
because what i wanted to do was see
family see friends you know back at home
seemed pretty two years for a long time
two years is a very long time and that
was like that's that was like my reset
right so before that like i was
definitely burnt out and i kind of just
dealt with it by just trying to fill up
my schedule and uh kind of kind of just
like ignoring it and i i didn't fully
realize that until i went back to
england and i just had nothing on my
schedule and i just realized
holy [ __ ] this is uh this is really
refreshing i'm getting a lot of ideas
and i want to go back to work i'm not
doing a single thing
is this what it's like to uh have a
break have a proper break this was like
to have a life
to just not do anything
yeah so i mean that's that's kind of
like what has been hardest in 2021
because 2020 was like what was the year
where you know the entire world was
flagged 2021 was like me waiting for the
world to get back to normal and it's
funny
finally finally looking like it is going
to get back to normal now yeah fingers
crossed touchwood are you are you boys
happy with your youtube channel this
year
yeah
which one joey which one yeah i i love
it because uh 2021 is the year that joey
refined finally became an annie tuber
yeah
just not on the end of the just on the
anime man channel yeah yeah i have a
i i told gant about it but uh because
i've been uploading a lot more on my
second channel now and i've been making
a lot more anime content on my second
channel now that i have a playlist on my
second channel called actual anime
content
just to poke fun but like yeah i don't
know um
i'm very harsh on myself when it comes
to my youtube channel and my content
stuff like that so like you know i'm
obviously proud of all the videos i
upload on both channels yeah otherwise i
wouldn't upload it at all but i'm
definitely not i'm [ __ ] not proud of
all the ones
but like i'm definitely one of those
people that's like
after a week of that like honeymoon
period i'm like yeah i could have done
better
i'll do better on the next one and then
i try and do it and i keep thinking i'm
going in the right direction then i'm
just like at the end of it i look back
at all of it i'm like
yeah like five percent of it was okay
yeah yeah
95
could have used a bit of work but i
think uh yeah like i have like plans for
next year for what i want to do with my
[ __ ] but like yeah i don't know it's uh
it's going to be scary because it's
going to be a lot different yeah like
pretty much everything i've established
up until this point so yeah see how it
goes but uh you know that's i guess
that's what we have trash taste for
right like as a fail-safe almost or uh
not so much a failsafe but like because
i guess like
yeah like a safety net i guess because
when we started again it's like when we
started trash days we were like oh yeah
this will be like a nice side project
for you to do you know yeah and like we
could do all sorts of cool things on the
sideline while we focus on our main
content but now it's like well we're
like 1.1 million subs or something which
is insane on the main channel thank you
again by the way yeah um
it's and you know now it's like pretty
much become like the main basket now and
our main channels and our side channels
and whatever else that we do outside of
trash taste has become the safety net
almost no like trash chase has become
like almost the number one priority no
it is a number one it is
when we need to schedule recording
that's getting done before any of my
[ __ ] videos or anything like any of
my scripts
exactly
so it's like you know definitely because
like we do have like lots of exciting
plans for trash taste obviously next
year uh which obviously can't tell you
but look forward to it um yeah i
definitely plan my work in greek my
working week around trash taste yeah not
the other way around yeah
um and i think just like that right like
that mentality is already just telling
of like this is out but yeah
but but also when there's i think
because all three of us are involved i
think it i i guess we probably pay more
respect to the the scheduling of trash
taste yeah all right well definitely if
i [ __ ] over my own channel that's my own
problem but yeah if i [ __ ] over the
scheduling with like trash taste yeah
it's like a burden to everyone yeah yeah
and you know we have we have people who
turn up to help us with trash taste so
yeah you know when i [ __ ] around doing a
monkey tier list on my own channel you
know if i don't do that it's you know
it's on me and yeah that's it right no
one else yeah yeah i think that that's
like i guess like going back to the
whole like getting a personal assistant
yeah or like getting a team yeah to help
you know behind the scenes of like my
main channel and stuff like that i think
that's the one thing i'm scared of which
is like i'm gonna feel more pressure now
to deliver on my main channel because
now it's not just me that i'm taking
care of it's taking care of a personal
assistant or like you know an editor or
you know a manager or whoever right
there's like multiple people's
livelihoods at stake right it's like
that's that's really the only thing i
guess that stopped me from personally
getting a personal assistant i don't
even know what to talk to them maybe
they'll realize i'm [ __ ] stupid i
don't know
like why am i helping it's a lost cause
no like for me i think the biggest
change for me this year is i guess i've
been really trying to figure out not
what i want to do but how i want to do
it i feel like you said this last year
in the year before
is it okay for me to say
did i say this last year you definitely
definitely said this last year yeah
because i i think this year has been the
year where i've really like knuckled
down to
try to really start thinking of my main
channel as like content as a job that i
have to like break down and uh like
actually be strict on how long it takes
to like make a video because right you
can't be taking months to make one video
no i mean like it's like because because
i think one big thing that has changed
since joining trash case right is that
for better or worse my content
my content upload schedule is compared
to your guys right and like especially
like seeing how your guys's content is
made like not saying like obviously i'm
not saying like anyone's content uh is
better or worse you know it's just like
i've kind of realized that
i want to upload as much as you guys but
with with the workflow of my kind of my
style of content i've tried to like cut
as many many corners as i can
and there is like there is just too many
bottlenecks that i can't i can't do to
like to like like i've i've reached max
productivity that i can reach with my
channel and
before
last year i was like i can improve i can
do better i can do like three videos a
month and trash taste and now i've kind
of i've come to realize that
not only is that setting the wrong
expectations for me to feel like i can
do it and you know i feel bad if i don't
do it but it also like sets the wrong
expectations for the viewer as well
because if the viewer is expecting me to
upload that many videos a month and i
kind of like
i kind of keep doing that
then that's that's just going to be
unsustainable and i'm just going to burn
out which which i did do this year but
that's like i didn't burn out because i
was putting myself in through too much
work i burnt out because of the world
situation but i've just realized that i
need to like i need to make a schedule
which is sustainable and
unfortunately you know it's for better
or worse like i
my upload schedule does get compared to
your guys but like i've come to i've
come to realize to not feel guilty about
that anymore yeah
you know i've when i make jokes about it
yeah yeah i don't give a [ __ ] but i i
don't think it's a like just sound a bit
of fun yeah i also don't like i've never
considered
i don't think that me or joe have ever
thought that your channel your content
and channel is comparable to ours in any
way like i don't think one upload is
equal to one upload on
no no i'm not like definitely not like
like it's it's
i guess it's like forced me to like
really break down a workflow to like the
video right because like
how long would it take would it how long
does it take you guys to like make one
video like hour-wise would you say that
varies yeah yeah that varies literally
like two hours or like a hundred yeah
yeah
yeah
there are some videos that like even one
now that's really it's like a really big
video i've been working on that i've
been wanting to do for a very long time
yeah a lot of moving pieces and a lot of
a lot of a lot of love edits and a lot
of footage to go through but you know
that no matter even if i put like a
month's worth of like like let's say if
you just took the hours i put into it
let's say it's like just a a full
working month of hours into one video
yeah it doesn't [ __ ] matter because i
got uploaded the week after anyway so
yeah yeah exactly but then maybe the
week after it'll be something that took
me two hours so it's it's it's kind of
you kind of have to juggle it but also
not make it look
like all these videos are like
completely different quality yeah
exactly which is why i kind of just
realized okay the only way i can make my
videos not seem drastically like
different in uh feeling uh theme
quality production is to just have i
guess
me being an idiot and me my personality
being like the focal point yeah exactly
the video or at least the main aspect of
the video yeah sorry so like so like i
had to break down for like let's say
like the fastest video you had to break
down yeah so had to break down like my
video making process like the fastest
video you can make is like say in like
two or three hours right let's say
you're like you needed to get a video
out so i've had like a few times where i
just need to get a video out right so
that's at the time on my end not doing
editing yeah yeah yeah yeah so like for
me like i need to like pencil in let's
say let's say i'm doing a video about an
anime right so i have to pencil in hours
like around about a day to watch the
anime which like assuming it's like a
season of anime right and then let's say
two days for
two two days for scripting which is like
one day for the actual script one day to
like finish the script and actually make
it like a good script you know and uh
and so that's that's already three days
right and then i have to
have like you know two hours or so two
two hours for like the recording of the
script and then nice and then i send
that off so that's like on my end
three and a half days already
um to be sent off to the editor now the
editor edits it and he has to send it
back to me and i have to do like the
finishing touches upload
and
um finishing touches upload thumbnail
and title which if i'm really lucky
would take half a day so that's like
four days basically
of workflow from beginning to end let's
say and that's if i'm fully productive
and
nothing goes wrong right that's the
fastest i can make a video of you to
assume i don't procrastinate now so
that's that's four days in a week right
trash taste is one day in a week yeah
right
i also want weekends as well
so now you just wish for thinking you
have that boy
i've realized like in my previous years
when i've been able to do three videos a
month i've been able to do three videos
a month and trash days because i've just
i've just worked on weekends and i've
just realized i kind of want weekends
and i kind of also want to do other
things like stream and
like maybe focus on some side projects
as well and i've just realized i'm
trying to put too much on myself and
there's like with the type of video i'm
making there is no way i can make this
video faster than the way i'm making it
and people will say well why don't you
become like a personality based channel
like you know you guys where you know
you know you can do different kinds of
content that is more focused on any
personality and i've played around with
that and then i've just realized no i
kind of i kind of like enjoy what i do i
kind of i i like scripting i've i am you
know i've already i've already got trash
taste i have a channel that is based
around my personality so called you know
and so i've i've just like i've just
realized that my main channel is always
going to be
a max cap two uploads a week uh two
uploads a month if i'm lucky three
uploads a month and i'm not going to
feel guilty if i don't make that if it's
one upload a month because i'm traveling
or because i'm on holiday that's what
you're getting and like i guess this is
a message to you guys as well which is
i know i know like i know the image is
it's just like oh gods are late it goes
to lazy bum who doesn't upload that much
but uh trust me i am working at full
capacity and you guys are getting two
uploads uh you guys are getting two
uploads a month maybe one upload a month
if i'm busy that month but
that is me at max capacity and i'm not
going to try to pretend that anything
else is that you know i honestly never
saw a problem like you know as much as i
like you know poking fun of it or
whatever you know in episodes and stuff
like that i honestly never saw a problem
with
your upload schedule um because again
like i know how much work goes into the
content that you make specifically like
you know you say you take two days to
make a script i sometimes take like a
week to make a script because i'm
nowhere near as good as making a script
the two-day script happened this year oh
yeah right before it would take like
maybe like three days or four days
before i can't script yeah but i feel
the more scripting you do the the better
you get at it because you understand you
know the basics of how to get a script
down right like you know i remember the
first script i wrote took me [ __ ]
forever because i was like how do you
write jokes i i've never written a joke
down in my life and performed it off the
script right so it's like
yeah so you know
i i would see like your upload schedule
and then i would see your videos and i
would think to myself all right if i
were to make this video how long would
it take for me yeah and then i think to
myself yeah it'll probably take even
longer than it probably took gone yeah
right and that's why i've never really
seen a problem with your upload schedule
if anything i think like i'm i'm
honestly even thinking like for next
year i'm thinking to maybe go to like
something similar to your upload
schedule as well because i want to put
because i think this year the thing
that's changed with my channel is that
like i've definitely upped my quality of
content or like yeah i've upped the bar
of the minimum standard that a video
should be yeah and that has resulted in
videos not only taking longer to make
yeah and to edit for mood on but also
it's taking longer to prepare just in
general yeah so it's like
right now especially these last couple
of months that i've been in like a
little bit of a burnout um i've noticed
that like
a week and one video a week is starting
to get tough i i actually forgot i had
to upload the other day
yeah right i was so busy i mean
especially legitimately i just forgot to
upload the video and then the day i was
like it was like midnight and i was like
oh i could upload it right now because
it was
supposed to go up in three hours but i
had to wake up at 4 am to do a call yeah
so i was like [ __ ] this i'm not i need
like these three hours of sleep i'm
getting yeah yeah right so but it's like
especially with us too now that we've
like put more effort into our second
channels as well right yeah and on top
of trash taste every week and then trash
days after dark every week right like
that's already so much [ __ ] on my plate
that i realized like oh if i continue
this
uh you know once a week schedule if i or
if i kind of lock myself into this once
a week schedule i'm either gonna
completely burn out yeah i'm either just
gonna be so [ __ ] exhausted that i
can't do anything or you know worst case
scenario both and the quality of my
videos is just naturally going to go
down yeah i've been toying with the idea
of uh just
not uploading all january doing the
classic youtuber move oh yeah i was like
i kind of want to like just do streaming
all month so and i thought january is
the best month because that's when you
get like
ad revenue you get a zero ad revenue and
that's the youtube a month that everyone
takes off because they don't get much
money yeah yeah yeah yeah but i was like
i do actually want to try doing like
streams uh full month see how it goes
and yeah have more of a consistent
schedule with that because i feel like
i've invested a lot in the streaming but
i'm still like in compared to other
people who are full-time streamers i'm
nowhere near as consistent yeah and i
think that's one thing that's like is a
detriment to that because people always
complain like connor i never know when
the [ __ ] you're gonna stream yeah and
i'm like yeah i know but that's what i
like about it
i like that i just turn up and i'm like
all right we're just gonna stream for 12
hours now casually let's do it i think
yeah but i think like trash taste has
definitely done a good job with like you
know to varying levels uh or or varying
results like trust's kind of like gotten
us to kind of look at our main channel
stuff and being like i could probably
change is it actually a main channel is
it like i just say main channel for the
purpose of main channel i really don't
think about like the only
it's weird now individually it's weird
now
i didn't even think of any channel as
the main channel i'm just like i just
make [ __ ] some of it has priority over
the other ones yeah but it depends week
by week which i'm prioritizing because
because like part of the reason why i've
been uh putting down the uh not not like
i've been putting the same amount of
videos on the main channel now which is
two videos a month and i'm not going to
try to do more because i want to do two
videos a month huh i thought you did one
a month no i only did i only do one a
month when it's uh when it's like a
polygon
yeah yeah so yeah yes so right now i'm
doing two videos a month um and i'm
putting all my extra time into i do also
want to like make a second channel
because that seems fun you know
it's super fun i see you guys doing it
and i'm just like you know what maybe my
main channel doesn't need to be my top
priority you know i've got like the
formula down for my main channel and now
i just wanna i just want this extra time
to do other [ __ ] now because i was
thinking because i have like a lot of
ideas for like big projects that can go
to my main channel right which which i
am sitting on
um but my god they're going to take so
much [ __ ] time yeah um and i'm like
doing these big projects really takes a
lot out of you especially when you're
also trying to maintain your const
consistent upload
schedule on your main channel anyway
yeah yeah so i've kind of come to
realize that you know when i really
really feel like i'm down on youtube and
i need to work on a video without that
i'm really passionate in then i'm going
to start doing those but for now
like i want like i want to do more more
small stuff i wanna i wanna i wanna do
yeah
i think the thing for me was i there was
a you know because i
i'm not sitting here saying that my main
channel is quality by any means i think
there is some level of effort that goes
into it and uh i'm going to have to
harsh myself would that not be quality
yeah
i don't know if there is a certain point
there's a certain bar that i try to do
on the channel for most videos there are
sometimes like i did like a [ __ ]
which chris loves to joke about yeah my
monkey tls video which i just wanted to
do because i thought it was fun but it's
obviously you know it's not it's nothing
like exceptional yeah but you know in
general the videos that i have were
quite difficult but you know sometimes i
see someone doing like a you laugh you
lose challenge i'm like that seems fun
i'd like to do that yeah i'll do it live
instead i'll do it on the the other
channel because it works and so it kind
of came to a point where a lot of fun
ideas that just weren't
big enough or weren't uh exciting enough
to like
warrant putting a lot of time and effort
into that yeah just kind of work really
well on the other side
because that's that's what i've noticed
well that's why i want that's why i want
a second channel because i feel like i
have set a bar of quality on my main
channel and i've like tested
uploading videos that maybe have not had
as much time put into them and use you
do see it in the view numbers if um like
eventually so that's why i'm just like
okay let's just keep my main channel for
like the contents big boy videos for the
big boy videos for the videos that my
audience expect to me but that doesn't
mean you can't do other things on the
second channel yeah it's like you know
there's like so many like especially
timely things or you know like so many
things that perhaps have nothing to do
with the [ __ ] i'm known for right that i
want to talk about in the video like you
know when youtube brought out that news
that they were going to get rid of the
dislike button right i was like i want
to talk about this in a video but i
can't just put up a 15-minute rant of me
on the channel
so it's like perfect i have a perfect
outlet for random [ __ ] have you how many
do you get the comments of i don't watch
the anime anymore watch joey yeah a lot
i mean you know that's fine and
everything because it's like you know at
the end of the day it's still me right
so it's whatever and you know it's weird
right because especially this past like
two or three weeks uh i've been
uploading a lot more on the second
channel and i've just like i found
myself waking up and thinking to myself
all right what should the next channel
on the second channel oh the next video
on the second channel
oh wait wait i have a main channel [ __ ]
i should probably think about that one
as well right i think because another
big thing as well is um i i feel like
right now with my main channel it i've
definitely seen the plateau of just that
kind of anime content yeah like that
kind of amazing concept and you know i i
do i do have like ideas about how you
know you can i could i could keep that
channel growing and grow past the
plateau but the the amount of time and
effort that would take
would to to me that would take too much
time and effort that i just don't have
right now that would take giving up
trash taste basically yeah to uh to make
content and rebrand my channel to a
point where it can grow plus past the
plateau of that kind of vanity content
right how do you feel about the growth
on your channel your main channel uh i
mean i'm i'm fine with it because
because i know like right now any tube
as it is has just plateaued like that's
you know we've seen the plateau if if
there are any other antitubers who would
like to prove me wrong please because
you know i'm i'm waiting for that one
person to prove me wrong yeah i i'm
waiting as well because i need i need to
kick up my ass to be like oh you can go
higher okay that's like my motivation
because like
i'm sure your you guys are the same way
it doesn't matter how many subscribers
you have right what i find what what i
find happiness in is growing something
or like making making it feel like i
have made progress on something so like
i felt way more fulfilled seeing the
progress and growth on trash taste than
i did on my own channel for like last
year yeah and like that's why i'm the
thought of a second channel excites me
way more than even making big videos on
my own channel because even if i make a
big video my own channel which i'm
really passionate in i know that there's
a certain cap for like the number of
views that's going to get and i mean
it's already like you know especially
with like all of our main channels like
it's it's already at a size where we're
pretty
happy with right and it's like it's it's
massive to a lot of people right so it's
like yeah yeah it's just it just makes
more sense that like you know obviously
you're gonna have more excitement
watering this tiny plant than watering a
giant tree right yeah obviously watching
this tiny thing grow into something
bigger is going to be more fulfilling
especially if you're trying to do
something that you otherwise not really
known for perhaps it's like content that
you've never tried before and stuff like
that and i think that's why i've been
having so much fun with the second
channel but like yeah i don't know like
and so like my main channel grew as well
like i hit 3 million subs this year
yeah right but like to me it's like i
don't know like i know definitely past
me would look at some months of my
channel's growth and being like oh man i
didn't really grow that much at all but
like i think i've just rewired my brain
this year to be like if it ain't a
negative then it's all good dude like if
if every day i'm gaining at least one
sub i'm i'm completely okay with that
now because i haven't been canceled yet
yeah exactly it's like if if people are
still like looking at my [ __ ] and
wanting to come in
cool dude like my doors are open but
like i'm not i'm not at this point now
where i'm like oh [ __ ] i only made 20
000 subs this month i'm slowly dying you
know it's like yeah the channel yeah i'm
like don't chance like oh no i'm just
past that point now like i'd much rather
put in the time to like be like oh i
have this tiny second channel that i
want to grow into something big so let's
let's focus on that kind of thing or you
know with like trash taste for instance
right yeah yeah like that that's way
more exciting for me and i think that's
why you know at least you and i have had
a lot of fun doing the second stuff
right because it's just like streaming
it's just something new right it's fun
yeah did you start like properly
streaming this year or did it start last
year i can't remember it it almost feels
like you've been streaming forever like
properly properly like consistently i
think it was this year right it's been
more this year than it was like well
last year it was 2009 no 2008. when was
the chess tournament the first one
uh early 2020 yeah 2020. okay well 2020
was around when i started streaming okay
and then i think yeah this year is
probably where it's growing the most
i've been a lot more consistent been
doing a bunch of stuff with that yeah
it's interesting
i still occasionally get people coming
into the twitch being like i had no idea
you had a twitch channel yeah oh yeah
yeah i have that every time i stream
yeah
i guess it's a different platform right
yeah it is a different platform yeah
yeah is there any changes you guys want
to make going into the next year
uh i'm just continuing what you're doing
now
i guess just like i don't know for me
new year's resolutions
youtube youtuber new year's resolution i
will probably i'm gonna hit a million
subs on the second channel there's
probably gonna be a point uh because i
you know when the world does open up i
do want to travel a lot more yeah i
actually like have a bit more time to
relax so there'll probably be a point
where i'm uploading a little bit less so
i'm not i'm not really too bothered
about it all right i'm just gonna say it
now just exp expect less uploads on the
main channel i think just because yeah
for one i want to put more effort into
each video now i don't want to like be
confined to this once a week schedule
and like
you're not gonna talk about what anime
you're not gonna watch no probably not
if i do that'll be on the main on the
second channel where actual anime
content exists
subscribe
but uh yeah i don't know like at least
with the main channel like i think i
know what kind of content i want to like
focus more on on the set on the main
channel from next year but that is
definitely going to force me to not
upload every week yeah just because it's
going to be impossible yeah i think last
year my new year's resolution was to be
more productive and to upload more and
then as i've just said this year i've
kind of realized yeah that i tried i
really did because i went i went like a
good like four months where i had like
three videos a month and i'm just like
yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm just like
before we went to the uk it was like
pretty consistent what's it really yeah
yeah yeah [ __ ] you don't watch it right
it was literally just before the office
move and then and then it took like all
right [ __ ] [ __ ] three weeks
it was around the same time so it was
like the first
the first half of the year um and then i
realized okay my my
resolution was just unsustainable and
i'm like i've accepted that yeah so my
new year's resolution is i want to do
more collabs and it's not going to be on
the main channel which is why i want to
focus more on another channel
because i've kind of realized collabs
just don't work for the dynamic on my on
my main channel yeah yeah that's that's
what would you mean what about our
collab on our collab remember that one
that one the one collab that
i mean because like i want to do less
something that's like not scripted and
i'd feel like any anything i script and
collabs uh anything uh anything i do on
my main channel has to be scripted so
that that video was obviously scripted
um i also just wanted like more time to
work on like side projects i want to do
a week-long live stream at least at some
point i'll do it at some point good
just double it
it's just stubble yeah there's that one
easy did i not like break you no
three days three days would like easily
break me off like three hours
i think i made a mistake of shouting
during one game too much getting angry
yeah and it [ __ ] my throat for like
the next day and then obviously it
wasn't having any time to heal because i
was just talking all day yeah and so
that was a rookie mistake but do it
again i'm not going to shout as much
not as angrily
but
actually the sleeping in that [ __ ] bed
was kind of uncomfortable i didn't
really get good sleep that was one thing
no yeah i i
wouldn't with the fact thousands of
people yeah with the [ __ ] rave going
on in the day it was the bed the bed
sucked
i'd probably just do one night where i'd
go and sleep in my nice bed and i'm like
oh i'm rested boys let's get it let's go
come on must keep streaming yeah yeah i
don't know yeah no i i want to do that
at some point i don't know when though
yeah and i mean like i guess like in the
case with like trash days as well like
because you know we're the world is
hopefully going to open up a little more
next year yeah we're just going to be
really busy with that [ __ ] as well like
the workload for trash taste has been
upped as well right because we don't we
now we stream every week if you didn't
know um until at least until christmas
comes along which
around now but uh once the year rolls
along i i want to continue the weekly
streams yeah i just work right
but like what that means is that we we
basically just recording another podcast
every week we have two trash tastes at
this point yeah we have
if there wasn't enough of my schedule
already there's there's another thing to
tick off the main channel
it's another trash taste recording
somebody added up all the runtime of
trash station it was longer than like
all of dbc or something
or something like that i believe that i
would still rather watch that
and uh
i've rewatched episodes there and all of
them oh my god regarding trash though um
i
we uh we figured out earlier that we've
only uploaded one special this year
oh yeah which was the cycling special
back in february which we filmed the
year prior
so uh wait will the figure episode count
as a special
just kind of it's like half a second
it's like a mini special yeah yeah i
guess i guess it's special in nature
yeah not a name
because we're still in the office yeah i
mean we had the cycling special and then
we've had like some mini specials like
the figure special the pc build special
um but i guess i guess it truly is like
top gear now where we get like we get
like once once a year one big special
yeah and every other week it's just like
the normal day two specials a year right
yeah that's probably a healthy amount
yeah i i think two special yeah well a
big portion of this remember remember
when we first started doing specials we
were like
four a year let's do it all right that
ain't happening
well because we had we had like we are
just like
back then we had our main channel and
trash taste and that was it
now we have our main channel you guys
are doing your second channel streaming
trash taste after dark um and then we
gotta do our specials on top of that
easy
moon on teach us how this is done
and people wonder why we want assistance
yeah right
i really i'm like genuinely considering
it for next year i think i think it's
gotten to the point where i actually
will it's not a matter of if
i need one or if if i want one it's i
actually need one otherwise i think i'm
gonna go insane no i've i've been trying
to look for one as well but i want i
want an assistant who's in japan which
is very hard yeah otherwise i'd just
like [ __ ] fly allen over or something
yeah
um but yeah i am also definitely looking
for an assistant
this is sponsored by manscaped ho ho ho
gentlemen the holidays came early thanks
to manscape hell yeah the leading men's
hygiene brand manscape just launched new
products including their all-new ultra
premium tm body wash and a 2 in 1
shampoo and conditioner it's time to
give yourself and somebody who needs it
the gift of beautiful skin hair and
balls this holiday season go to
manscape.com and use code trash taste
for 20 off plus free shipping inside the
performance package 4.0 you'll find the
signature lawnmower 4.0 this electric
trimmer has proprietary advanced skin
safe technology to reduce the cuts on
your nuts did you know it's also
waterproof so you can use it in the
shower it's like a gift to your partner
with less mess it also includes the crop
preserver and crop reviver an
anti-chafing board deodorant moisturizer
and toner it's time to keep your north
pole feeling and smelling fresh wanna be
south this hygiene bundle will also come
with a pair of manscape tm anti-chafing
boxes that'll keep your junk feeling
fresh all day the perfect package for
your perfect package so you can get 20
off plus free shipping with the code
trash taste at manscape.com that's three
percent off and free shipping at
manskip.com by using the code trash
taste clean up your nuts and make santa
proud this year thank you for sponsoring
these nuts you guys had any regrets this
year
oh [ __ ] that's a [ __ ] question
just gonna drop that bombshell nowhere
no
me neither
you don't have regrets i'm trying to
think i just i just that question just
came up from the top of my head not
going to
[Laughter]
as we found out on the trash taster
stream
i actually regret not putting more time
into japanese because my japanese
studying has been like very spotty this
year i'd be like super into it and then
like something would happen and then
like i would take a day off and then
that would just like stack one to like
two days and three days and then
suddenly i'd find like a month had been
taken off of learning japanese and then
like the first
like the first few weeks of me getting
back into japanese is just like me
relearning the [ __ ] that i already knew
before right it's kind of like the gym
in that day right where in that way
where you make your gains and then you
stop going and then when you go back to
the gym you got to like regain the gains
you already had yeah it just feels like
really demotivating it's like trying to
push through it sucks i really wanna go
to the gym more
but i'm just lazy
yeah are you are you just lazy or is it
just because you have
got so much going on in your life now
that you just don't have the time
i mean if i really really really wanted
to go to the gym i could make time you
know what i mean like but but it's it's
not something that i enjoy as much as
other stuff but i really do want to go
more yeah also some days after i've like
after i've been and you know you're hurt
for the next day and
then the day after that i'm like i'm
like not not great feeling 100 but it's
the only time that week i have time but
i'm like yeah
maybe i'll go maybe i won't ah yeah yeah
it's tough it's tough it's really
annoying i don't know my schedule is a
lot more unflexible now so
i think i have times to go it's just a
lot difficult a lot more difficult to to
get it in in the way i wanted it to yeah
because i think because you just have so
much more [ __ ] going on right so like
even if you are at the gym it's like oh
[ __ ] you're just thinking of all the
stuff that you could be doing otherwise
yeah
it just feels better right i travel a
lot more for videos as well now so yeah
that takes yeah it feels it feels weird
that there was a point where the sea dog
channel was just you inside filming
videos yeah
video is not outside i'm just like kind
of slacking man kind of slacking what's
going on
this is what i'm worried about because
i'm like [ __ ] all right so let's say i
want to go back to the uk at some point
what the [ __ ] am i going to do on my
channel everyone's going to be like why
isn't he outside like what was there to
[ __ ] do in the uk
just try every pint in weather yeah yeah
it's not bad actually
i'd watch that try every meal deal at
tesco
i'd do that too
i've already tried them all but i'll
tell them yeah do it on video
i don't even know what i would do like
yeah i'd basically be like shitty tom
scott at that point
this is this is a house where they they
get water through a well it's really old
and stuff
that's like the uk we don't have
anything interesting
we only have like really old quirky
stuff in the uk we don't have anything
modern that's like [ __ ] insane
yeah i guess that's why everyone travels
outside
stuff right i legitimately don't know
what i would do with my main channel
content if i ever move back to the uk
don't worry i don't have time uh plans
to it's not happening it's not happening
anytime soon yeah just boys keep me
hostage uh
i don't know what i don't know i would
do i mean this check titled trash taste
keeps me hostage
yeah that's the thing that's weird
having like having a specific spot i
need to be in every week like a job and
when we have to take holidays now we
have to tell the boys and put in our
holiday time
to be like hey i'm going to be away for
this week um so uh yeah i mean we could
just put in the hours ahead of time
right yeah we could just like not have
trash taste some weeks but then also
it's like why why not we can easily just
make it every week yeah yeah exactly and
i i'm not a fan of like the whole uh not
uploading on holidays because i'm like i
only like some of my audience celebrates
said holidays so i i don't feel like
it's fair to just be like oh [ __ ] you
guys people who don't celebrate the same
holidays as me
i'm not giving you content i'm busy i
mean it's a valid excuse i think in some
ways when you're like you're busy but
you know i also like uploading and i i
like the trash taste uploads every every
every week no matter what yeah it's like
no matter how uh not what people are
doing it's like you can expect that
you're going to get a trash taste every
day it's kind of like comfort food
because i like that about channels i
watch that like no matter where i am
even because sometimes you know maybe
christmas i got some down time you know
for an hour or two i might watch a video
that's come out that i'm really excited
for you know exactly i like it i like it
but the thing about christmas right it's
that okay so you have you have
you have the beginning right you wake up
early
with the family you open presents and
everyone opens their presents everyone's
all merry and happy
so what happens between like 11 o'clock
to four o'clock food and alcohol
no food alcohol and check this [ __ ] out
no because
food comes on at four right so what
food comes out about well you don't you
don't have like a christmas lunch
i mean like
for christmas lunch whatever you want
what whatever you envision food a dinner
to be dude i'm about to have like an
all-you-can-eat buffet for dinner you
bet you better know that i'm saving
space for that christmas dinner well no
i have that buffet at lunch and then
don't have dinner i have both because
during dinner time i'm busy getting
drunk no dinner dinner time christmas
dinner it's like it's like one of the
best meals we don't do that in australia
what do you do in australia though in
australia we wake up we have we get the
you know open up all the presents or
whatever yeah uh and then you know by
that time it's right lunchtime yeah and
then all the family comes over you have
like you know kind of a late lunch maybe
like two three o'clock type of like big
big lunch
finish at like 5 p.m and then that's
when you get shit-faced with your family
and by the time dinner time rolls around
you're not hungry because you're still
full from the massive lunch i think i
have lunch and dinner christmas yeah
it's like a lunch industry yeah it's for
me it's like it's one big meal no it is
one big meal for me
how can your stomach handle yeah it's
christmas baby
that christmas spirit man like i i think
large is my stomach by four times like
the reason we don't have a christmas
lunch or i've never heard of anyone
having a christmas lunch is because i'm
pretty sure during christmas dinner you
eat enough to like fill yourself up for
a [ __ ] week well sometimes like you
have friends who can't come to the
dinner or something so i'll go i might
go meet them for lunch or something
going out on christmas day yeah i'll go
now blasphemy i'll like go to their
house
what you don't spend with your family no
no i'll spend the dinner with my family
because maybe there's someone who i
don't spend all day with your family
not all the time sometimes i do it
depends on like who i can see when and
when i can't you know some people they
have like they're having a christmas
thing and i'll go and say hi i'll turn
up and then i'll go back and spend the
evening okay so like last time i went
back to australia i did that like i i
spent like a christmas dinner with my my
friend at my friend's place like my uni
mate but i did that the day after the
actual christmas event as like a late
christmas kind of thing right right
right but like on christmas day if i'm
not at home with my family no then
something's wrong if i'm if i'm not at
home with the family or we're not going
to another one of our family's relatives
places yeah then there's there's some
beef what's going on
some of them are friends some of them
are family you know it's kind of a mix
you know
okay but like my justification for the
christmas lunch in australia is that you
have to understand that christmas day is
a very nice summer day
right so
going outside eating a massive thing by
a pool side is very normal in australia
yeah pass me the turkey i'm in the pool
right now yeah exactly so you don't have
a roast no we do okay but outside
it gets cooked with the sun because it's
so hot yeah yeah yeah
we we pop off we just have a [ __ ]
barbecue basically not even we just go
out onto the road and just pop a whole
chicken on the tarmac and then it just
cooks by itself
no but like it's it's like a usually
like you know mid like 34 35 degree like
nice summer day right and it's like
you're out on the balcony with your
family and you're having a you know a
nice roast or you know pork or whatever
it is that you eat yeah you know during
christmas and we have that during the
day because the sun's out and it feels
good you know that's that that's my
justification of why we have one meal at
like two o'clock
obviously if it was like that's so alien
to me yeah obviously it feels like
winter time right yeah i'm not going to
go out
okay yeah i'm right okay okay so
so as as someone who obviously grew up
in australia celebrating christmas that
way yeah do you do you have like this
christmasy feeling like what what do you
have a christmassy feeling or do you
have anything that gives you a
christmasy feeling yeah christmasy
feeling is when i'm having uh a beer at
like 2 p.m in a pool
that could be that's like any day for
australians joey like it's yeah
christmas
hell yeah
is it like weird watching christmas
movies
we don't watch christmas movies at all i
don't know at least our family doesn't i
mean australians do you have like a
christmas spirit like uh like
like they are like dead inside no no no
no no why are you sad joey tell us why
you are sad because i remember because
uh when when i lived in thailand uh me
and sydney celebrated christmas there
for like two two or so years and every
every year she'd she tell me you know
what you know the trees up we got we got
the christmas we got the christmas songs
on the roast is out but it just doesn't
feel like christmas she says as it is
like 35 degrees and like yeah yeah yeah
yeah you're outside no just listen
it doesn't feel like it but it just just
doesn't feel like christmas i mean you
know we put up a tree and everything and
you know we decorated it and put the
lights on it and stuff like that but
it's also you know i'm in my board
shorts and t-shirt at the same time that
just
that just doesn't sound festive to me
it's like it's like board short board
shorts t-shirt christmas hat you know
there's a yeah there's a great photo of
me like just with exactly that get up
standing in front of the christmas tree
sweating my nuts off because it was like
38 degrees okay okay okay so like is
there like a certain period of time
where you see something you know and
you're like oh christmas is coming up
you know because for me right like in
england you know it's it was whenever
the weather would start getting like
really cold and then you'd start seeing
you know christmas decorations pop up
here and there what is it like in
australia
it's the same thing is it the same you
see christmas decorations pop up but at
the same time it's like oh i gotta start
taking this jacket off
oh my god that's so bizarre
that's how we do it do you get any
houses which like go absolutely [ __ ]
mental oh yeah christmas decorations
yeah absolutely
absolutely absolutely
but the problem is right but the problem
is because it's the summer time right we
can't turn the lights on until it's like
9 p.m
because it's still bright outside sorry
for [ __ ] santa claus and like with
like a like a hot red jacket oh he ain't
in a whole red jacket he has no shirt on
dude
he's in he's in red board shorts usually
no shirt
you have like like snowman decoration
and [ __ ] like that oh no i know you know
actually
snow in australia uh in some parts it
does yes so in canberra it does
um but not not where i'm from no not at
all it doesn't get cold enough it's like
the coldest it'll get maybe it's like 10
degrees oh yeah yeah but again like that
happens in july for us not uh not not
christmas it's still strange what's
christmas for you connor what dream
like
what's your christmas
what is your christmas his christmas is
not spending the whole day with his
family i don't know i like spending the
day with my family is christmas like a
special day for you not not like does it
mean some of you but like it's you you
know you know what i mean where's just
like is christmas just like
the day i'm indifferent towards i don't
feel anything particular on the day yeah
i like spending it's a good i like the
idea of spending time with the family
you know it's not like [ __ ] mark
zuckerberg right now don't i i like
human activities i like seeing people on
the day of the 25th
i'm cooking a skillet
barbecue sweet barbecue race
sorry
bob mark zuckerberg sorry i love that
meal
you know i to me it's like
it's i don't know it's i like watching
the christmas movies they're fun i like
i like the jingle all the way that's my
favorite one jingle all the way what's
that one where uh arnold schwarzenegger
tries to buy that uh figure for his kid
oh that one i didn't know the name of
that one
yeah
that movie is so good that's my favorite
christmas movie um yeah i i don't know
it's uh i like christmas eve a lot as
well actually in the family because
everyone's kind of like everyone's
starting to warm up everyone's uh kind
of like getting uh yeah getting that
family vibe it's weird because christmas
eve for us is a normal day
i don't know we don't do anything
special because every night we kind of
like all kind of like talk you know
watch tv or yeah drink you know have a
nice meal
i'll talk to my mum and dad or then i'll
go somewhere and then my brother will
you know what i mean like he's never
like the whole units together yeah yeah
even now because you know all me and my
family all of us live in uh me and my
brothers all live in different areas
my brother's gonna go to canada now as
well oh [ __ ] so it's gonna be even
harder to get everyone in the same place
i i was the difficult one because i was
on the other side of the world but now
everyone's gonna be the difficult one
yeah so i hope hopefully i'll get to see
because i didn't get to see my uh my
older brother when i went back to the uk
because he was busy doing stuff in
scotland i think or something are you
going back this year
what the christmas this year no no i'm
not okay i don't want to deal with
travel again
um
i feel that i lost enough of my lifetime
once because you didn't go to america to
see sydney's family right yeah so i
guess that's fair enough i i don't have
anything like that so i i saw my family
they got to see me i'll see you next
year
i'll probably go back at some point in
april or something and see them again
wait was it your parents that said that
they would probably never come to japan
no
why is that no no no no they they never
said that oh
well what why they want they want to get
super yeah well why not next time you
know when the country opens up they come
here oh yeah maybe that too because i
don't think they haven't come to japan
before either no no no my parents really
want to come to church yeah as well i
bought yeah my christmas present was
flights for them
like last year
do christmas presents roll over
i'm like what oh yeah you haven't
redeemed it yet so uh oh my oh man it's
sitting there waiting
yeah no they want to they really really
want to they've i've really sold them on
the idea when i first moved here they
weren't too hyped on it but yeah after
they've watched after i moved here they
kind of watched a lot more stuff about
it and they're really excited to go
which is great because i can't wait to
see how utterly confused they are
um but yeah i'm really excited for them
to come over um
and yeah that'd be fun when the last
time you did spend christmas with your
family then
it must've been a while right uh the one
before japan so 2000 right 2019 i was in
japan right yes 2018 christmas then damn
damn that's been a long time
i guess so yeah that's three years right
yeah
uh yeah three yeah three years ago
because the first the first christmas i
just moved to japan in october and i was
kind of settling in yeah so i was like i
won't come back i'll come back next year
next christmas that didn't happen
and then come out this christmas either
do you guys ever cook for christmas or
who does the cooking for christmas oh my
dad my dad dad yeah because because like
it spent like 12 hours yeah the day
before that's just like two days so like
what i've always wondered is when does
the torch get passed over right
because when you have your own kid's gun
yeah because you have no choice
hopefully not for a while because i need
a lot of catching up to do
because yeah i mean um yeah i've started
cooking my own roast as well and i'm
just like i kind of like how my roast
cooked but i don't think it's as good as
my mom's yet but i'm just like i'm i'm
gunning for it eventually but also
for the title also i don't know when in
my life i want to like spend my entire
day cooking because when you cook a
christmas never you're just like as a
kid as a kid you have comfort in knowing
that's like that's like the parents job
to like deal with you know you're out
here having fun with your family they're
out there just cooking and all that [ __ ]
for an entire day and i'm just like
when is that gonna be my job i'm kind of
dreading that when uh when a little baby
man is appears in your life i guess
that's that's when you get started joe
don't lie you're just gonna make aki do
it you're gonna be like honey honey well
i mean
well you know every thanksgiving she you
know spends like an entire day cooking
food and i'm just like oh [ __ ] that
i'm not doing that are you kidding me
you get to enjoy the fruits yeah exactly
i get to just enjoy the food right so
yeah i don't know like i've been
thinking that too because like because
like every time because i i guarantee
when i go back for christmas yeah uh
which i will be by the time this comes
out um my dad is gonna force me and be
like son
it's time you learned the way no no no
no no he's gonna he's gonna he's you're
gonna be in the other room he's gonna
email you do your shot yeah
he's going to leave a youtube comment
dear son come in my last video hey son
help me with the roast
[Laughter]
yeah but like you know every time i do
go back home and he because he cooks
every night um right i i do you've got
to learn the family recipe right yeah
right and i like i've learned some of
you what's your dad's like specialty my
that's specialty uh my nut specialty is
moroccan chicken wow yeah that's nice so
he he bought like this like proper like
moroccan uh like uh pot type of thing
that has like the kind of funnel lid
on it uh which is like apparently what
they use in morocco please correct me if
i'm wrong about that but um yeah it's
like spiced moroccan chicken with dates
and lemons yeah it's so good i'm
definitely gonna make get him to make
that when i go back home but it also
takes like six hours to make and i'm
like
i mean i love to have that
yeah every week in my house but i also
don't wanna invest in a [ __ ] pot let
alone spend six hours cooking this thing
you know well that just means you
haven't reached that point in life yeah
i know when you settle down in a house
you're just like maybe uh maybe have
some spare time to uh start a hobby
maybe i should uh yeah you know because
there are some like kitchenware which
you never use apart from like that one
event in the year right yeah
when you're like a teenager when you're
like a teenager you're just like why
would i need this thing this is just
taking up space right i hardly have any
space in my kitchen as it is but you
know now especially moving into my new
house i'm just like i remember going to
connor's house and i'm just like oh
connor this this cutlery it feels good
it feels good connor god uh this isn't
this isn't daiso cutlery
i bought ikea's finest
i i did actually feel a little bit like
when i helped uh aki last year for
thanksgiving and she she made like a
turkey
like a whole turkey thing because we
bought an oven finally and uh you know
the gratifying feeling of me going honey
bring out the oven tray
it was just like oh this is a special
day
we never bring this thing out oh my god
oh it's a special event
so i i am going to be like that i am i'm
already like that with like tools
you know because i've i've you know
slowly which what kind of tools like
like diy like you know like oh okay okay
like hammers and like all that kind of
[ __ ] right because i still don't own a
hammer yeah
not in japan wait what i don't own a
hammer hammers are quite useful yeah
they are quite useful a mallet maybe
like a rubber matter this is like pretty
good i have a rubber mallet yeah yeah
but you need it
you never you never know you never know
but when you when you need it you're
like thank god for [ __ ] yeah whenever
you needed one in japan like having to
like knock some screws out of place or
something or nail nail some things down
to like prop maybe an artwork up or
something or you know whatever the ikea
table was being annoying with the screw
i needed a hammer to push it in making
like like tables and stuff like that you
just like kind of knock it in it's
coming a lot more i can't tell you every
use about for it but i remember i've had
multiple times i've been like thank god
i finally bought a hammer yeah now that
because like when we the our current
place that we're in because we have two
balconies right and like building those
balconies i was like oh i am missing
like 90 of essential tools so i just
went out a day to like tokyo hands or
whatever and just like binged like blind
pinchbook binge boy
i just i just like splooshed on all
these tools it doesn't binge anime
anymore binges ninja's tools binges
hardware yeah
and like not gonna lie that was probably
one of the most fun shopping experiences
i've had
i sure do oh my god do you have a power
wait what where can you use a power
drill in japan many places because like
because because after a while because
like especially when you're buying
furniture like when you first make so
when i was first building my my room i i
was like okay i have a much bigger room
now i'm just gonna replace all of like
the desks and like shelves and
everything with like much bigger nicer
places that fit the atmosphere right so
obviously when you buy stuff from like
ikea or amazon or whatever they don't
come in one piece you gotta [ __ ] diy
that [ __ ] right yeah i've i've
definitely been feeling that for like
the past
don't you hate it
twisting the [ __ ] screwdriver for 17
hours in the week
and to the point where your wrists and
your thumb starts to get sore i do
regret not buying i guess yeah yeah so
like furniture yeah i regret it so when
i bought like my new bookshelf i i still
had the screw right and i was like oh
good this bookshelf has 50 screws that i
have to screw in and they're hard as
[ __ ] as well by by the time i finish
like three hours later my hands were so
sore so i was like [ __ ] i'm buying a
power drill because though i had another
shelf coming in built that [ __ ] in like
30 minutes because all i had to do was
go
and i was i was like
technology is amazing it's incredible
remember when ikea selling point was
like that you get to build your own
furniture and it's like all convenient
and stuff yeah and now i'm just like
i've ordered some furniture furniture of
amazon which doesn't need to be built
and i'm just like this is a [ __ ]
godsend
they're ahead of the game man
some ikea products i'm i think you can
pay them to assemble in your house yeah
you can you can because sometimes ikea
furniture is actually like really good
yeah because they have some things that
you know ikea has great furniture it's
just you know like paying the ass to
make yeah like
like especially moving into a new place
you know making making one or two things
that ain't too bad that's that's a fun
that's a fun afternoon when you're
making like 10 [ __ ] things in a day
you're just like
this thing just come pre-built and there
are some like there are some ikea things
where like even the way that you have to
build it is like some kind of artistic
feat where it's like [ __ ] algebra one
to get like a [ __ ] piece in because
it just looks so weird on the
construction thing
my table kind of broke a little bit and
one of the screws is missing but i
should be fine
yeah exactly it happens one of one of
the biggest things one of the biggest
things that annoys me is that i've now
that i've built so much furniture in the
past few weeks i i know what kind of
packaging is just like good and
optimized and what is awful right so
like i was building i was building a
shelf yesterday and like every single
screw every single compartment every
single plank had like a number sticker
on it or like came in came in came in a
bag that was labeled as a certain number
yeah and that's great because you look
at the instruction manuals and you see
ah this number of screw goes into this
number plank yeah yeah i [ __ ] hate
the
the the furniture that gives you a bag
of screws and then you get the
instruction manuals and it gives you
like 10 different kind of screws
it's so [ __ ] hard trying to
differentiate like a screw that's this
length and a screw that's this length on
the instruction manual and i just like
that could be one of ten screws which
screw am i supposed to use no the one i
hate more than that is like when it
tells you like okay you have this many
screws right yeah you should have ten
screws and so i go to count and i'm like
why is there 11 screws
that's not the screw then i realized one
is just there for a spare right here but
they don't tell you it's a spare so you
just have to assume that one of them is
a spare so it's like okay because when
you finish building it and then you
realize and you look down and there's
like three screws left over you're like
yeah well i clearly [ __ ] up somewhere
some sometimes in japan they they give
you a pair of gloves with your furniture
yeah oh yeah yeah because for some
reason you need like they it's like to
not hurt your hands i guess when you
build it they give you like a pair of
white gloves it's really yeah i don't
know it's cute yeah it's really cute i
never wear them because i'm like what
the [ __ ] would i wear gloves
i think but i actually i don't like they
give you these shitty screwdrivers and
like allen keys oh yeah it's such a
waste yeah i buy like eight things and
now i have eight [ __ ] screwdrivers that
i have to get rid of i i have a cupboard
of just the unused allen key yes
like the shitty screwdrivers are less
common than the allen keys yeah well i i
bought my own set of allen keys yeah
same thing all like perfectly measured
yeah and they're great really good
quality and it's so much better than
using these tiny ones where you like
destroy your palm trying to do that last
turn
they clearly don't understand the
concept of torque yeah
they're not like long enough
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's so easy just
like yeah and like the quality of for
some reason there are some furniture
that the quality of the screws it's just
like all over the place [ __ ] there's
some that are just like perfectly
ingrained you can get yourself drivers
steel enhanced nails and then there are
some which i swear like pre-sheared so
you so like you turn it it's like a [ __ ]
it's like a [ __ ] ice skate right it's
just slipping in and out and i'm just
like how how am i supposed to get this
career the worst feeling is when you
like go for that like it's like it's
like this much of the screw is still out
and you turn it and you feel it sheer
yeah and you look at it and it's like
already sheared you're like
it makes like that horrible like
so
you have to like fully like put your
full pressure on it yeah and not stop
because if you let go it will shear it
yeah yeah yeah you're like [ __ ] i gotta
give this in before before i [ __ ] the
shop
is everyone keeping up
you know what we're talking about right
just furniture things just middle-aged
guy things but yeah i've just noticed
that like since you know having the
balcony and having so many like new
things to build like that i i've really
enjoyed building furniture like on
ironically george llamas
come to my house and build my furniture
that's all i've been doing honestly dude
i'll happily do it it's actually so fun
i don't know it's it's like i bet he
won't if you actually were like joking
around this time he says it's on camera
camera turns off yeah yeah i'm busy i'm
busy that day
no honestly like you like buy me lunch
or something i'll do it all right okay
i'll like dead-ass help you out because
you ever like consider making your own
financial like
pro going proper deals like buying the
water yeah i have actually thought about
it but at the same time to make what i
don't know just something i don't know
but like you know maybe like a table or
[ __ ] i don't know whatever but like
i have thought about it
i have actually thought about it but
like yeah because i don't know like i i
took woodworking
uh like classes a little bit in like uni
yeah um because it was like a thing that
we had to do um but like i wasn't it's
weird because i i specifically remember
i [ __ ] hated that course like i
really did not like doing like diy [ __ ]
yeah and it's not until
suddenly i've like moved and i've got
all this like i think you know what it
is it's not that i enjoy diy it's that i
like the feeling of getting new
furniture
so that that that just changed
drastically as a post
but it's like it's i think as well it's
like it's nice because i mean you guys
have seen
me in this like trance-like state when
i'm building [ __ ] yeah where like i
literally just turn on music yeah and i
just am in my own world as i'm like
making
furniture or like whatever it is like
when i'm making something it's like i
think i like that feeling because it's
almost meditative to me no i i like the
feeling of buying furniture that's
that's that's that's a good feeling
you're like i i knew i was eating on my
furniture when it's done
like i knew i was old where you go
through the ikea catalog and you're just
like oh that that's a good that's a good
looking desk right there
now you're gonna go there in person guys
gonna go to the ikea mega store you
gotta sit down you gotta feel the chat
um
buying furniture become fun dude [ __ ]
welcome to a dollhouse baby you know
what was the most annoying part of
i bought that uh that ikea grass [ __ ]
right yeah yeah
it's just like generic grass that goes
on your yeah your uh
whatever the [ __ ] you want because i
wanted to have some grass so i could
like cause it feels nice yeah it's good
feels good so i bought it turns out
though those ikea grasses like the one
thing that sucks about them is that like
you can't measure them
you can't like fit them in precisely
yeah all right like they either fit or
they don't yeah i can nearly have some
of your val patio covered or you won't
right
they're like squares they're like
they're like ah i think they're like
five by five i don't know oh you got the
you got the squared tiles yeah yeah oh i
got the ones because yeah i just got the
roll because my balcony is massive
because ikea does like square tiles of
fake grass yeah yeah yeah yeah and so i
didn't really consider how it would fit
but i roughly measured it i thought
hours
yeah realized there i can't block the
the drain
uh the water drain yeah otherwise no
water again obviously
so so then i was like okay well now i
either have like a big chunk of my patio
not covered and it looks weird yeah or i
have my drain cover which i can't do so
why not cover it with like there's
there's because i know the tiles there's
like a wood tile which has holes in it
can you just put that there i have some
wood towel on the other side okay well
what about if you get the square and you
cut a hole that perfect so here's the
drain and then you just pop it on top
because that's what i did at my place
okay so what i did it's not it's not
it's not it's not like um one big drain
the drain's in the corner somewhere else
but it's like the thing that leads into
the drain oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
stuff needs to be occurring in it yeah
so i was like okay [ __ ] i'll cut the
[ __ ] in half yeah it's it's it's like
rock-solid plastic oh
know it is impossible to cut the shoe i
was like what tools did you use to cut
it
my willpower i literally like got this
piece of plastic
it's like this big right like this not
even a saw i literally just like spent
it together with my hands like this
right and then i just kept bending it
like that yeah and it weakened and then
i did it the other way but the other way
it's all plastic so it hurts your hands
to bend it because i'm [ __ ] bending
it so i bend it the other way and i just
kept doing this and it got loose enough
where i got some pliers and i was like
cutting the plastic along jesus christ
so goddamn long and then i had the
problem of okay because of how these
towers work there's only like there's
two sides like the one 90 corner right
90 degree yeah this side and this side
are like the holes that you connect it
to and these sides have like the clips
that it clips into yeah so i have this
problem now where some of it clips in
well some of it doesn't so i'm like
don't step on that one people when
people go to the balcony because i'm
like uh yeah you're just all gonna like
[ __ ] break and fall apart if you step
by but it looks nice yeah we got it
perfect yeah it looks like i hurt my
hands and it took so goddamn long
that's why i like the roll variety
because it's it's designed to be cut but
but like i didn't have a big enough area
to warrant a whole roll yeah yeah it was
a small area i just wanted grass i
wanted to see more green yeah yeah
because i i in my previous place i just
had like the wood things oh those are
the wood towels which look nice but also
i just prefer the feel of fake even if
it's fake
oh yeah it feels great yeah that's why i
got some parts wood just for to to have
that over there i was like oh
i got grass for where my feet go
there's something about with touching
grass with your feet feels good
what can i say we touch grass yeah they
touch grass every morning next time you
consider insulting me remember i have
grass and that i tell you whenever i see
even if it's fake wrong whenever i see a
comment that says touch grass i'm like
don't mind if i do it i go out to my
balcony
so much girl
do you wait do you have a garden in
australia when you were growing up did
you do a garden yeah my dad had a
massive garden oh yeah my smile my now
now that my dad's retired it's like all
he does yeah yeah garden would you ever
consider a garden
i know i want a garden i don't want to
look after said god that's the point
right
the idea of a garden is nice um because
we have a garden in our
english home as you know you've been
there um and there was a point in time
where my parents would just go to
thailand and there was a point in time
where i would work from home
at that house and then
in the months that they were away i was
just i noticed that the garden just
progressively looked like [ __ ]
and the grass would grow and that was
that at that point where i realized
oh someone's gonna take care of this
garden for it to look good
i don't want to do that that's that's so
much effort it's a big garbage plants
are alive
plants are living things
and
ever since you know ever since then i'm
just like the idea of a garden is nice
but just i've seen a lot of people like
sydney's house has like a massive garden
and you can lose like half a day or
something just like taking care of it my
dad regularly spends multiple days
taking care of it multiple days i'm just
like he loves it though it's like it's
like his new child but it looks amazing
to be fair he does a really good job but
to me it's just like i i think i would
absolutely love it if i had the time to
take care we haven't got to that age yet
we can appreciate just being able to
like pull out the lawn
you know have your coffee or your beer
and just just go at it yes exactly just
just grab a hose and just hose down is
that a good thing i don't know like when
you get older you'll probably enjoy
those pleasures more yeah because
because
because i remember when i was a kid my
mom would be like go on go cut the grass
now it's it's your turn and i'm just
like for [ __ ] they never made me do that
did they have all the other choices oh
they made me do that i [ __ ] hated it
because to me it was my dad's like he's
not i'm not letting him do it it's it's
my garden it's mine he's gonna [ __ ] it
up
my dad was like if you don't do it then
no dinner tonight and i was like okay
yes father
and i do it and i i i hated it i wanted
to do everything else
that's why i like the fake grass i'm
like
i hated putting out the laundry that's
what i hated i still hate putting on
laundry well sydney does actually
certainly loves that [ __ ] but the way it
was in my house is that we had like just
a line and a big stick that props up the
line in the middle yeah
yeah so it was always [ __ ] annoying
when it was windy doing this when i was
like like small as well and this pole is
massive so i hated doing it
press memories by the way i don't like
doing the laundry now that's because of
you
childhood trauma they [ __ ] hate that
pole piece of [ __ ] they still use this
poll as well
get a new poll get better i'll upgrade
your poll look at the new poll like i
remember i remember uh when i moved to
my new place and you know because one of
the big thing about my new place that
we've added um
is a dishwasher which uh as you guys now
you guys have dishwashers now right
i sure do yeah completely changed my
life and my mum at the beginning my mom
was like my mum my entire life right has
been like we don't need dishwasher our
family doesn't need dishwasher yeah like
that's that's just that's just what
that's just wasteful water that's just
like your water bill and your
electricity to be always going to go the
moment i found out the dishwashers used
significantly less water i was like well
that's my excuse for the rest of time
i'm like
and ever since like i've moved into my
new place and like i've shown my mum the
dishwasher and just like how much less
effort it takes to you know wash dishes
after you cook like a zoom call with
them like mom look
i press the go button
she's like um
i could be looking for a dishwasher for
christmas
conversion complete
i was like where where where was this my
entire life mom was i just your
dishwasher my your entire life and now
that i'm gone you you need an actual
dishwasher is that it is that it that's
pretty much i see how it is i see how it
is children are just cheap appliance
like conversions right this is like i
could spend a lot of money on uh you
know a lawn mower yeah or i could get my
son to do it with the shitty lawn mower
honestly one when i have children you
bet you're asking my children
you're describing why people had kids
like hundreds of years ago that's why
they had so many they're like well i
can't do it when you get married into a
house i was like all right how many
things do we need to do every day seven
all right prepare to have seven kids
paying for this i'm not paying for an
assistant i'm getting a kid
hiring a cleaner that's like privileged
rich people [ __ ] getting a kid
that's the real [ __ ]
that's a wife
one thing sorry to go on a tangent i
just realized [ __ ] kids for a woman um
please don't please
not that kind don't play soundpoint
music
one thing that i hope
i get less of next year
the only regret is that i haven't told
these [ __ ] nft companies that email
me every day to [ __ ] off
[ __ ] off stop emailing me yeah we're not
making nft [ __ ] off yeah we all we all
get them and i just it's not just emails
it's tweets as well did you notice on
some of the tweets where
it's just like a bot that gets like
retweeted it'll be like you can buy like
i don't know how me tweeting about like
anime tvs or something has anything to
do with [ __ ] nfts it's either it's
either this bot saying hey you can do
something with this nft or it's this one
guy who every tweet is consistently like
hey you should read this one i never i
never got visibly angry at an email
before but this one made me like i
shouted it was this one where it says
business invitation from the most
anticipated nft game i've never wanted
to hear that string of words ever and
and the fact that i got that email maybe
what the [ __ ] is an nft game
[Music]
i don't know i don't want it stop
emailing me i hate this [ __ ] bro i i you
know if you if you're into it that's
fine i don't mind but why do they shove
it down our throat because they won
every call because it's next-gen dude
it's next-gen everyone needs to be
up-to-date on that next-gen [ __ ] but no
because because what it feels like is
that this thing is this thing that i
have like very little knowledge about
it's just getting shoved down my throat
right i understand it and i don't like
it i don't even understand and i hate
still hate it i just but it's because of
the [ __ ] that they like the [ __ ]
stuff they say on twitter it's like
mind-numbing
since nfts has become somewhat worse i
don't understand how twitter got worse
but like nfts made twitter so much more
annoying and then every goddamn youtuber
is like somehow using nfts for like
scams as well it's all they are so many
youtubers using nfs okay can you can you
explain to to me and perhaps audience
that doesn't know explain it like i'm
five
what the [ __ ] even is an nft so there's
there's a there's like a you're
basically buying the the proof that you
own a piece of artwork right but it's
digital right but it's a digital piece
of artwork so it's not a physical piece
but in the in the blockchain which is
kind of i don't i'm not going into that
yeah don't go into it explain the like
on five explaining
like in like proof to the world that
your ba but essentially you are paying
for the proof that you own something
okay right that's the most basic way i
can explain it right so you get a token
that can't be replicated to say you own
this thing right so it's like a
certificate of authenticity no that's
exactly what it is right right that's
that that's why
people are buying artwork digital
artwork for like ridiculous amounts of
money because yeah
in in a sense even though you can
right click and save as that
like like there there is a token yeah or
like a certificate that says you own the
original piece of the artwork
even though even though it's like
digital like that's dumb as [ __ ]
i have friends good friends who uh like
have made a lot of money from it and
yeah that's what they do and they
produce them themselves and they you
know it's all for them i don't mind them
doing it i'm not like you can't do it
it's like just this whole this whole
aspect of shoving it down everyone's
it's just the craze right because people
are trying to make money from it yeah so
so the only way to get money and make
money from a lot of the a lot of them
not all of them are scams but there are
a lot of scams as well there are so many
scams and there's like so many uh
scandals and stuff because there's no
regulation or anything so do people like
buy certain nfts and then resell them
yeah
yeah yeah yeah okay so it's like an
investment so it's
that's how that's how they freaking have
a phrase
like there's been stuff like insider
trading where like websites that sell
nfts and showcase them they have like
things there was like one case where um
this thing where they basically promote
an nft every week and the guy one of the
like ceos or something knew which nft
was coming up so he would buy a bunch of
that that type of artwork and then when
it went up he would sell it and make a
ton of money but there's no laws against
it because it's not considered insider
trading because it's cryptocurrencies
yeah the cyberpunk so there's like this
it's just the wild west right now and
for some people it's great they love
that
it's a place where because because
there's no rules there's no regulation a
lot of people can get scammed a lot of
people can make a lot of money very very
fast um and it's just kind of like a
toxic environment right that's really
bad yeah it sounds like it's so many
scams and i hate the fact that youtubers
have started promoting them and doing it
of course they have of course that is
[ __ ] awful oh i've released my nfg
which is like a shame because i like
like i feel like the the idea and the
technology has like so much potential
and now it's just being used for like
really shitty things basically yeah and
you know there's also the criticism that
it's terrible for the environment and
stuff like that and
uh what not how's it terrible for the
environment oh because the oh wow god so
do i have to go do my own research the
way that like though how the system
works it uses a [ __ ] ton of computing
power to
have the blockchain okay it's quite an
efficient all right yeah in general it
it wastes a lot of energy to run these
[ __ ] nonsense yeah basically like
some of these cryptocurrencies at the
moment
have as much energy usage as some
countries to run right
yeah yeah yeah yeah
genuinely it's insane like like the like
the network that nfps run on which is
called ethereum i think uses as much
energy as like sweden or one of those
countries you know i'm not like i'm not
like this boomer who's like
anti-progress and anti-technology i'm
all for like good technology but it just
feels like the way it's been going is so
such a [ __ ] mess well it's like it's
just awful well because because it's
actually been shoved down my throat i
did actually do like my research and
reading into into this thing because
like if there's if there's this thing
like i like to understand things and i
feel like the problem the problem now is
that it's just so [ __ ] new
that yeah nobody knows what the [ __ ] to
do yeah it's the wild west and i feel
like as
as like as the years progress and it
becomes more stable then this could
there is potential for this technology
to be used for something actual good
actually good and it will i i feel like
it this technology will be more
sustainable in the future as well as
cryptocurrencies kind of figure out hey
let's let's build a system that doesn't
like burn the entire amazon rainforest
to get running right but i feel just
right now it is like i'm staying the
[ __ ] away from this oh yeah i'm not
touching it like the the knee
although that's the last thing they want
it does need some kind of regulation in
some sense to stop all these [ __ ]
scams and the reason why
i know how many scams there are is
because they always reach out to us to
ask us to promote them yeah there's so
many that ask us to promote them and
this is like this [ __ ] nonsense it'll
be like hey we're like a badger poop uh
nft uh we wanna and it's like [ __ ] off
just [ __ ]
are you off forward to nfts being added
to your favorite video games
i like i i think if it gets to a point
where it's like it's not like [ __ ]
burning the planet and it and it's chill
you know and and and
it's it's not so scummy because like
like i i see this [ __ ] i'm just like the
cs go skin community is like salivating
right now oh my god oh my god yeah nft
skins
came over but it'll probably get there
so yeah i can see it happening i can
easily see it happening if you're having
one of the kind of things i'm just like
so out of the loop with like that kind
of like honestly
like i feel like this is what my grandma
must have felt when vr was introduced
you know it's like where it's just like
i just can't
wrap my head around like i did ask like
i when you said ethereum like i was like
oh okay yeah i've heard of that because
when the first time i heard ethereum i
was like i'm pretty sure you can collect
that in starcraft right like
like that's what that's what it sounded
like to me and then i was like oh wait
no it's like a crypto thing okay never
mind i don't wanna
i feel very old right now i'm not bad
that's the only trend i hope changes or
dies down yeah yeah that's all i want i
don't care yeah
i just i just i just want some actual
cool applications that are not just
selling overly priced artwork which is
just the exact same [ __ ] artwork it's
it's
the amount of times i've seen that
monkey nft like we're just different
skins i don't even know what that monkey
nft is like oh well i've got the skin
boy he's wearing the pirate hat and it's
like [ __ ] off i realize how stupid this
sounds
oh god at least if some guy spends
talking 200 on a monet he's got a
[ __ ] monet but he's also i don't i
don't think he's good either but yeah at
least he's got the [ __ ] paintings
yeah exactly didn't burn down the
rainforest to get a [ __ ] token and it
was such a boomer i know i hate i hate
all this stuff man it sucks i just yeah
scam suck too and yeah again i hope that
it gets some kind of uh i hope that it
regulates up its act yeah because it
stops being so [ __ ] yeah because like i
was reading about up about like the
possible applications nfts could have
and like you know you know you have a
non-fungible nft stands for non-fungible
token so of course right now it's been
used as a certificate to say you own
this stuff but it has like a lot more
applications above that you can think
about hey sending over certification to
say hey this person let's say has a
driver's license or has like
has you know is certified has a master's
degree or something along those lines
where it's like one centralized unit
that anyone can check so we don't rely
on like some companies like
forging driver's license or
documentation or like having to go all
the way to like even thinking thinking
about house ownership or any kind of
ownership right yeah the amount of
[ __ ] paperwork or you know you think
think of think of how much it can
revolutionize japan if there was one
system that said this person owns this
and this person owns that that's like
that's like that's got so much potential
to like like
like reduce the paperwork by tenfold
yeah you got to give japan time they've
just discovered databases so you know
like
china still uses the phone
yeah they've just discovered what excel
is yeah like yeah maybe like 30 40 years
time for that no i i think there is a
lot of exciting things that it could be
useful yeah but right now it is that
sounds cool yeah right like yeah that
sounds like a real life use but you know
like i i remember like the only piece of
news i saw about nft is when it was
first popping up was like the original
nyan cat gif got like sold as an nft for
like
some some stupid amount of money and i
was like
who what i want to know is who sold it
and how did they prove that they had
ownership of it i think it might have
been the original creator
i don't know i don't even like the
original creator was like there's
actually a loophole for this we can't
actually like this concept is actually
not applicable to what yeah that's
that's that's that's the biggest leap
so what we're saying is we can't
authenticate whether it's authentic or
not yeah that's what they said what the
[ __ ]
yeah there's still a lot about this
place i don't understand so i'm not
gonna i'm gonna i'm only gonna comment
on things that i do know yeah yeah i
just want less
please less scams yeah so like for
example like a single ethereum
transaction consumes as much electricity
as an average u.s u.s household uses in
a work week and has a carbon footprint
equivalent to 140 893 these are like for
example our visa credit card
transactions or 10 595 hours of watching
youtube
what the [ __ ]
that's like every nft transaction that's
[ __ ] insane
why yeah right now right now it is we
truly live in a society
bro
bro
that's actually depressing that's so
depressing to her
[ __ ] what a way to end the year
well happy new year gamers happy new
year
hopefully next year you won't be as
depressed hearing them merry christmas
if you celebrate it if not happy
holidays if not have a good day i'm
gonna buy an nft of my favorite fortnite
naruto skin that's what i'm gonna buy
god i'm [ __ ] getting there okay get
me out of here get me out of here today
do they sell the gift of gun no jutsu
i want my recent gun thank you very much
i hope all these guys are having a very
merry christmas right now yes if not
happy holidays and uh thanks for another
entire year of uh trash days next time
you see us will be the first day of
2022. yeah that's [ __ ] terrifying to
say out loud
however
[Music]
oh there it is right now 20 years 20
22's
yes but uh if you'd like to support the
show for next year 2022 because we have
a lot more going on then make sure to
join us on
patreon.com also follow us on twitter
send us your memes on the subreddit and
if you hate our face listen to us on
spotify but uh yeah thanks for
20 21. thanks for an amazing 2021 uh you
guys i mean
it's been it's been a [ __ ] fantastic
year for trash taste
yeah we we've talked about our
individual channel but trash tastes just
like it keeps coming man and we don't
have to talk about trash days you guys
know how good trucks you guys do you
guys know how it is you're here every
week but uh yeah so we will see you guys
in 2022
bye
it's the most i've ever yawned in one
episode
[Music]
you